You
I
Not up on the right place
The House will come to order members will be at their seats the clerk has opened the roll and you may record your presence
Please rise and give your attention to the house chaplain followed by the Pledge of Allegiance led by representing bow high
Let us pray together
Your father, thank you for these gathered here to help make Kansas an even better place to live
I pray your wisdom to guide every decision made in this chamber today
Your word says this is my commandment that you love one another just as I have loved you
At times this can be difficult
Especially when our personal values conflict with others help us strive to be on the side of what is best for the good people of Kansas
I pray for your protection upon all of our
Representities as they navigate the cold and at times dangers weather visiting our state
I also ask for your protection on the families of each of these
Representities amidst the chaos and confusion gripping our nation
I asked the peace of Almighty God to prevail
Allow stability and civility to be exercised by all struggling with frustration and anxiety in Jesus name. I pray
Amen
Yes
All members had an opportunity to record their presence
The clerk will close the role and record the attendance
He can recognize his representative McNorton on a point of personal privilege
You
Thank you, mr. Speaker
members of the body
Standing in front of you today is a group of outstanding young ladies
They have accomplished something that very few athletes have earned the right to say
We are the Kansas 3a state volleyball champions
It coach Sarah Johnson led the team to almost a perfect record this last year winning 46 matches
By only losing one all year to a 5a school
They were undefeated champions in the big eight and big East league not the big eight
But they'd really be doing something then right
Three and oh and mid-season tournaments regional champs and sub-state champions
They also broke the Kansas sports Hall of Fame record for the most team assist in the season
This is a 10th time in program history that silver lake volleyball team has won the state title
With the addition of this latest volleyball state title
This will bring the total of 70 state championships for silver lake teams in their very long history of excellence
Along with the assistant coaches and other players up in the gallery the team standing here today is
Representing all the staff and students of Silver Lake high school
We have Paige Hyman
Paige Windsor
Lexi Newfeld
Jayden Wise unfortunately was sick and couldn't be here today Kylie Haney
Jaylee Whitehead
Karis tighter
Kenley Weber
Lila day
coach Sarah Johnson
Would you please join me in recognizing these outstanding student athletes
Mr. Speaker I ask in my comments be spread across the journal without objection so ordered
I
Be corrected representing chauncey on appointed personal privilege
You
Ladies and gentlemen of the body
I rise before you to present you Kansas Wesley and collegiate deck a team
Kansas Wesleyan answers its ninth year and collegiate decka
Clégica deck excuse me. It's comprised of 110 universities throughout the world
Institutions worldwide. Excuse me in Kansas. There are nine total deck of chapters from a couple junior colleges to
Kansas Board of Regents schools such as ku which saw state
Decca provides the students a unique competitive advantage before joining the workforce through Decca students and developed a skill set
Professional excuse me a professional writing business research case study in provision
Creating and designing visually appealing slide shows
Professional communications all while enhancing industry specific skills
Over the past five years kw you Decca has the remarkable says excuse me success rate at both state
Competition and international competition typically carrying a team roster of about 12 students
Kansas Wesley University Decca has a 98% of its students
Placing the top 10 in the world in their respective events
All edit the international competition placing the top three is monumental
Kansas Wesleyan University Decca has 33% of its competitors placed third in the world
almost 29% place second in around 36% of their
Competitor their students place in world champions. There's a lot of strategy according to their coach
Dr. P check here. There's a lot of strategy that they use in order to have a success. They've been having I
Think what she wants to emphasize most is the preparation that the students put into this
They put countless hours of work to prepare for their Decca projects
They competed at the state level and then go on to compete on a national level by qualifying
I'd like to recognize those here that have competed and the national competition are part of the Kansas Wesleyan University Decca
team
I'm starting
Courtney Ald
Shelby Davison
Delaney McMullen
play Ganyon
Jordan Grimes
Maddie McVay
And someone that's near and dear to me page Chauncey
I would ask that the body rise and show the appreciation for Ken's Wesleyan University Decca Club
We have multiple world champions here and
I would also like to recognize the family members and
Representatives from the Kansas Wesleyan University in the galley
We could also recognize those and speaker I'd ask that my words be spread throughout the journal about objection. So ordered
You
Reduction of bills and concurrent resolution the clerk will read
I'll spill 2568 by committee on federal and state affairs requested by representing
Will carpenter on behalf of the wildlife and parks Commission and that concerning administrative rules and regulations
HB 2569 by committee on elections requested by representing Wagner and that concerning elections
HB 2570 by committee on taxation requested by representative howerton and at concerning sales taxation
HB 2571 by committee on local government requested by representing prong and at concerning municipalities
HB 2572 by committee on taxation requested by represented Butler on behalf of representative Barrett and at concerning taxation
HB 2573 by committee on federal and state affairs requested by representing Birkamp and that concerning the Kansas Board of Accountants
HB 2574 by joint committee on information technology and at concerning cyber security
And a bill 284 is withdrawn from the committee on interstate cooperation and referred to the committee on health and human services
How's bill 2009 is withdrawn from the committee on interstate cooperation referred to the committee on health and human services
House bill 2010 is withdrawn from the committee on interstate cooperation and referred to the Committee on Health and Human Services
House bill 2328 this withdrawn from the committee on interstate cooperation and referred to committee on health and human services
services. House Bill 2375 is withdrawn from the Committee on Interstate
Cooperation referred to the Committee on Health and Human Services. Messages from
the Senate the clerk will read. The Senate adopts the Commerce Committee report on
HB 2347. Introduction of original motions and house resolutions the clerk will
read. House Resolution 6022 by Representative Estes a resolution
congratulating and committing the members of the 2026 Kansas Teacher of the
Year Team.
On HR 6022 the Speaker
recognize Representative Estes for a motion to adopt the resolution. Good
morning body across Kansas teachers get up early in the morning and head to
school to work with our children our students and one could argue that these
students are very most important handsons as they represent our future. Today we
celebrate those who have gone above and beyond to impact our students. The
teacher's heart is very special and we appreciate all they do to support our
children. We congratulate Rachel Marrow the Alletha Public Schools 2026
Kansas Teacher of the Year. We also congratulate our regional Kansas
teachers of the year Lauren Sage from the Kansas City Public Schools.
Trandis Strand from the Belleville Public Schools Susan Rogers from the
Derby Public Schools. Tracy Betts from Winter Public Schools Jason Peters from
the Heston Public Schools. Julie Smith from the Santa Fe public trails I'm sorry
Santa Fe trails public schools and Troy St. Clair to peak of public schools. I
move we adopt the resolutions and my words be spread across the journal. All
those in favor signify by saying aye. Aye. Opposed no. The ayes have it the
motion is adopted without objection so ordered.
All those in favor say aye.
Final action on bills and concurrent resolutions the clerk will read.
HB 2413 by Representative Swarchweiger and Steele an act concerning crimes
punishment and criminal procedure relating to theft providing that theft of
livestock or implements of husbandry is a severity level five non-person felony
allowing for the forfeiture of certain property used in the commission of theft
of an implement of husbandry. This constitutes final action on House Bill
2413 the clerk will open the roll and you may record your vote.
I've all members had an opportunity to record their vote. The clerk will close
the roll and does any member desire to explain his or her vote does any member
desire to change his or her vote in 10 how hands call the houses or the door
men will close the doors members will be in their seats and the clerk will call
the roll. Alkala Burke West bow high Bryce carpenter will Chauncey how how
well Halbertson Proctor say Pinkton Simmons Tark was singer will born Wilson
and win. Representative Proctor votes aye. Representative Carlin votes aye.
Representative Perquest votes aye. Representative Saphington votes aye.
Representative Will carpenter votes aye. Representative Bryce votes aye.
Representative Wilson votes aye. Representative Turk votes aye.
Representative Wossinger votes aye. Representative Howe votes aye. How not how
actually representing how votes aye so you can get both of them. Representative
Wilburn votes aye. Representative Simmons votes aye. Representative Howardton votes aye.
Representative Chauncey votes aye.
Representative Moseley votes aye.
Representative Bohai votes aye.
Not seeing ten hands call is raised. There are no pictures to be taken of the
board if you're taking pictures in the gallery no pictures. Are there any
further changes the vote? Seeing none 120 having voted in favor and three
against the passage of House Bill 2413 the same having received a constitution
majority the bill is hereby declared passed. The clerk will record the vote.
Final action on bills and concurrent resolution the clerk will read. HB 2422
by Representative Swartz-Figer and that concerning crimes punishment and
criminal procedure relating to theft providing the theft of grain as a
severity level six non-person felony. This constitutes final action on House
Bill 2422 the clerk will open a roll and you may record your vote. As I remember
had an opportunity to record their vote the clerk will close the roll. Does any
member desire to explain his or her vote? Does any member desire to change his or
her vote? Representative Simmons votes aye. Representative Rivas votes aye. Representative
Roser votes aye. Are there any further changes the vote? Seeing none
10023 having voted in favor and zero against the passage of House Bill 2422
the same having received a constitutional majority. The bill is
hereby declared passed. The clerk will record the vote.
Speaker recognizes Representative Humphreys for a motion to adopt the
conference committee report on House Bill 2347. Thank you Mr. Speaker this is
House Bill 2347 you all have heard about this it's the crime package from the
judiciary committee there are four crimes in here it has to do with the
couple changing the culpability of a motor vehicle theft our human trafficking
bill which includes buying increasing the penalties for buying sex and also
educational and treatment program requirements. The third crime is the
criminal use of a financial card of a gift card and the last one is the
unlawful use of a laser pointer and with that I will stand for questions. Is there
discussion? Speaker recognizes Representative Osmond.
Thank you very much Mr. Speaker. We discussed this in last week in
conference or in caucus before hand but we didn't get a chance to you really
go through so yeah it the carry of the bill did an excellent job explaining it
it's theft it's buying sexual relations both of those passed so 40 to 0 on buying
sexual relations it was 121 to 1 on theft of the motor vehicle it was for
financial use of gift cards it was 123 to 0 as the original amount and an
unlawful use of a laser pointer it was 40 to 0 in the Senate and it was 123 to
0 in the in the House. I will say there was a question that was brought up the
question of about use on law enforcement so if it is used against law
enforcement engaged in the performance of an officer's duty it will be a class A
misdemeanor a class A misdemeanor being up to one year in the county jail or
up to and or $2,500 as a fine whether that sways your opinion one way or the
other I'll leave that to the body to decide for me I'm in support of the
entire CCR and would urge your support. Thank you. Any further discussion?
Representative Humphrey you may close. Thank you Mr. Speaker I'm to adopt the
conference committee report on HB 2347. This constitutes final action on House
Bill 2347 a clerk will open the roll and you may record your vote. As I remember
had an opportunity to record their vote the clerk will close the roll. Does
any member desire to explain his or vote? Does any member desire to change his
or her vote? Representative Johnson votes aye. Representative Anderson votes aye. Any
further change of votes? Seeing none 119 voting in favor and four against the
passage of House Bill 2347 the same having received a constitutional
majority the bill is hereby declared passed the clerk will record the vote.
Following committee changes I hereby appoint representing Kyle Hoffman to
replace representing Susan Humphrey's on the House committee on rules and journal
on Wednesday January 28 this appointment expires at the end of the day on January
28. I hereby appoint representing Bob Lewis as a chair of House Committee on
Rules and Journal on Wednesday January 28 this appointment expires at the end of
the day on January 28. Speaker recognizes majority leader
craft for a motion to resolve into the committee of the whole. Mr. Speaker I
move the House resolve itself into the committee of the whole for the purpose
of considering those items another heading of general orders. You've heard the
motion all those in favor signify by saying aye. Opposed no. We always have it the
motion carries. Speaker appoints representing Proctor to chair the committee
of the whole.
Good morning body the first item of business is SB 244 for the purpose of
carrying SB 244. The chair recognizes representative Humphrey's.
Thank you Mr. Chair there were committee amendments and I moved to adopt the
committee report. You heard the motion. You heard the motion all in favor
signify by saying aye. Opposed no. Motion passes. The report is adopted.
Please continue. Thank you Mr. Chairman. So I want to talk about Senate Bill 244 it
has two parts to it. In section three of the bill it is clarifying the legislative
intent concerning the motor vehicle driver's license act. It defines gender to mean
the same as defined in KSA 77-207. New section two clarifies that the sex on
the birth certificate matches the definition and 77-207. In section five
which amends 65-28 comma 137 a it's clarified that sex or gender mean
biological sex either male or female at birth. Because of court cases that have
come up there needs to be clarification and this section of the bill is needed to
clarify what was the legislative intent when we pass this bill. That's the first
part of the bill. The second part creates a law requiring the designation of
multiple occupancy private spaces in public buildings or used by only one
sex and it creates enforcement mechanisms for that. It includes requirements and
it includes a lot of exceptions and it also includes the enforcement measures
if someone wanted to bring a case. It does not prohibit a single occupancy
space. That is the overview of the bill. I have a feeling we'll get into the
details and with that I will stand for questions. Does any member wish to
speak to the bill? The chair recognizes representative Osmond.
Thank you very much Mr. Chair. There are many people here today that will speak
knowledgeably and passionately about this topic and about what's included in
the bill but I'm a rules guy and I want to talk about the rules. I want to talk
about policies and procedures and what's fair and what's definitely not fair and
this bill is not fair. Procedurally it is the absolute worst bill I have ever
heard in my time in the Kansas legislature. It was introduced on the
House floor first day of session January 12th. That afternoon about one
o'clock two o'clock and we've been to judiciary and in a planning committee at
about 3.58 p.m. they published the agenda to add what was then HB 2426 to a hearing
less than 24 hours after publication of the agenda. Less than 24 hours and it
was done with one purpose and one purpose only to ensure that the absolute
least number of people were available as opponents to this bill and that they
were unaware that there would even be a hearing. No one wanted to hear upon a
testimony on this bill. Nevertheless they received over 200 pieces of
opponent testimony. So much so we couldn't even review the testimony prior to the
hearing. We couldn't even see it. It wouldn't be uploaded into what is the
best drive our internal drive system to review documentation until two days
after the hearing. Even today even today as we debate the bill the
testimony I do not believe is publicly available for anyone in the gallery to
view and read.
Flash forward a week and a half and with no warning we work the bill on Monday
the 26th. They introduce and pass three separate amendments each one designed to
take away the public's right of notice and ability to fight back. First amendment
please keep the conversations and sidebars to a minimum please continue thank you
Mr. Chair. First one is they moved the timeline a passage from July 1st of
2026 to the Kansas Register. In other words immediately once we pass this bill
it effectively becomes law. They added a completely unrelated portion to include
the regulation of bathrooms and I want to tell you why this is unrelated. We
challenged your maintenance and it was denied but I'm going to renew unofficially
my call that for germaneness because of how this bill came about in its own
place. This bill came about because of in 2024 we passed the Women's Bill of
Rights and we said up here this is a bad bill it's going to be challenged legally
and it was it was challenged and it went through the trial court they sided with
the AG it went to the appellate court and the appellate court had the most scathing
smackdown of the of the attorney general I've ever seen. It is burns my hands even
touched the document. They effectively said to him hey if you're going to make a claim
you need to have evidence and if you need if you're going to make a cause
that there's harm you have to prove up your case in some capacity this isn't
even law 101 this is freshman year debate 101 this is going back to essays
that you had in your sixth grade class where was a third three paragraph essay
where you actually showed what your what your stance was with proof that's
what they needed and that AG couldn't even provide that there was no harm
available to this and to deal with this and the third thing is this there is no
fiscal note and I want to point this out there is no fiscal note on this because
of the amendments that we added to this to this document including moving it over
to SB 4244 there's not a fiscal note there will never be a fiscal note we are
talking about modifying immediately regulations and physical bathrooms across
every municipality county school board public library police department across
the state of Kansas and we do not know how long it will take to implement how
much it's going to cost we have no fiscal note we will never get a fiscal note and
the reason we will never get a fiscal note is because of the third thing we
moved this bill into Senate bill 244 that is a bill that has already been passed
and it means procedurally because it's already been passed we can bypass the
democratic process and we can take this bill that we're working on today can
cur it over to the Senate and throw it up to the governor's office to to vote
on to to either accept or veto there's no debate in the Senate there's no public
input in the Senate there's no testimony from your municipalities that you live
in that are going to have to deal with the fallout and ramifications of twenty
five thousand dollars to 125 thousand dollars every single time they screw up
on a bill that gets implemented immediately we need input from the
public and by the way if you want to try to follow this in this in the system you
can go back you can look at Senate bill 244 which still lists is
introduced by senator Owens as if that's what we're talking about here today and
if you try to go you go oh there was a hearing on HB 24 26 what's going on
with that thing right now you go online and the last the last thing is Tuesday
January 13th hearing that's it that's what the public knows there was a
hearing on January 13th and that is the end of the story for that bill we need
input from the public we need input for municipalities we need a fiscal note to
tell us how much this is going to cost the set state in liquid damages fines and
fees for non-compliance in the law this law could go into effect within a month
and how much will it cost every taxpayer in the state of Kansas we don't
know I'd like to know so I make a motion to refer SB 244 back to judiciary for
the purpose of reverting Senate bill 244 back to HB 2426 that way if we pass
this in the house at least we will have public input from the Senate and at least
we will have a fiscal note
this is a debatable motion does anybody wish to speak to the motion okay the
chair recognizes representative Carmichael thank you mr. chair I'm sorry to
those of you in the gallery the mics a bit sensitive this morning I'll try to
stand back all this motion does is re-establish what in many bodies called
regular order bills are supposed to be noticed to the public bills are supposed
to have hearings the public's input is supposed to be received and heard and
then bills are supposed to be debated on the floor then they go to the chamber
for the very same process through a crafty procedural device what has been
attempted here is to short circuit regular order to deny the public the
right to comment on a bathroom bill it's been deliberately designed in a way so
that the public had no notice of the filing of a bathroom bill the public had
no opportunity to testify either in person or in writing on a bathroom bill
presumably it's going to be reported out of this house and it's going to go
over to the Senate on a motion to concur with a shell bill following a
gut and go amendment in committee that will effectively once again deny the
public the opportunity to be heard about this important legislation no matter
what you think about whether we should keep transgender people's out of bath
people out of bathrooms as important as I think that is you certainly ought to
defend the rights of your constituents to be heard if you don't agree with
your constituents then you go ahead and vote as you wish but most of us listen
to our constituents most of us want to hear from our constituents most of us
even go knocking on doors to talk to our constituents but if you think you know
better than just shortcut regular order cut the public out of the discussion
don't worry about how much it costs don't worry about the impacts it may have on
local governments don't worry about the impacts it may have on children in your
district when Harry faced men walk into bathrooms because their birth
certificate says they're female just go ahead and do whatever you want but if
you want to reestablish legitimacy in this legislature and if you want your
constituents to be heard whether you agree with them or not then this is a
device to accomplish your goal and I therefore stand in support of the motion
thank you mr. Chair do any other members wish to speak to the motion the chair
recognizes representative Esau
thank you mr. Chair there are people much more eloquent than me on this bill
and I didn't intend to talk to it when I went home yesterday but for reasons
that have absolutely nothing to do with this bill I ended up in a conversation
with some folks and started talking about what we were going to discuss
today and I know for some people this might be a brand new bill you've never
heard this topic you've never seen it discussed in the legislature but I can
tell you it's not new there have been hearings things like this have come up
they've had many conversations but the folks that don't come the silent ones
are the women who have dealt with assault at some point in their life
sometimes at home sometimes out in public sometimes at school they don't want to
come and testify and say why they feel safe in women-only spaces they don't
want to go through that trauma again they've moved on they'd like to put it
behind them but if they are in a place that they believe is for more than one
person but only one gender and it's their gender and they feel safe and they hear
a male voice in the background the trauma starts all over again I've had
folks tell me they won't go out in public they won't go to public pools where
they have to go to a locker room that sort of thing for generations we have
protected women in women's spaces we need to continue to do that for the women
they should not have to come here in mass numbers and tell you that they have
been traumatized in order for us to do the right thing this bill doesn't need to
go back for us to hear that for us to have the women to come in and tell us
their concerns we know if you don't know I'm going to tell you there are people
in this chamber who may have told their mother they may have told their grandmother
an aunt a friend they never reported that trauma they found a way to get
through it on their own they healed from it but they don't want to have to deal
with it over and over again not knowing that they are safe and safe places I
urge you to not send this bill back to committee let's vote on it today let's
have this debate as we're having right now and vote the bill out I believe this
bill is ready to be passed and there's no reason to debate it further thank you
for your time
sir any further discussion on the motion the chair recognizes representative
Haskins thank you mr. chair and hello studio audience up there this is going to
be an exciting day but we can we can curve this and end it and go on to
lunch if we look at this motion seriously now for those that are new to the chamber
this is your first time around there are some rules that we have to follow one
of those rules that is very specific is that you need to keep in mind that nobody
in this chamber can vote for you so if you are guided and directed to follow suit
keep in mind that you have to make the decision based upon your constituents
and it upsets me when we rush things through that deal with my constituents
and my constituents they don't get a say and that's what happened here
winter winter chicken dinner you guys read the rules and you found a way to make this work
but if you're fine with understanding that you didn't have a voice in representing then you don't
vote for this motion you continue on keep in mind if we continue on the hounds are coming out
and we're going to have a good debate and talk today so I leave that leave you that with an
incentive last thing I will say is this i'm looking for a new car car broke down
I will never buy a car without knowing how much it costs
it really annoys me when someone buys a car for me spends my money and doesn't tell me how much it
costs folks we represent individuals who are paying our salary from their tax dollars to have them
be represented by informed honest debate with integrity if you want this debate do it right
and the thing is this is a trend I don't know what's going on yesterday we've had committee
meetings without information we didn't we heard a bill we didn't have a proponent just because
we have the power to do it one day we get you can look back and you can see the
harms that we have created and ask yourself that I really do my job representing
my district the people that voted for me not the people in this room so take time take this serious
we can have the debate you can have your bill do the homework and let the people be heard
support this motion let's go to lunch have a great day
city other member wish to speak to the motion the chair recognizes representative car
thank you mr chair
would the carrier of the motion please stand for a question
thank you very much sorry about that yes i will oh well there you are
um my question is essentially why are you bringing this this motion why is this
important to do the motion is important to do because i believe in policies i believe in
a proper procedure and proper procedure is number one public its input and number two
we have a full um process that includes the senate i know a number of us don't wish to
include the senate but they were a bicameral legislature
we need to have a full senate hearing period
so was this at all ever about um about women's space
no i mean the original bill itself was it basically the attorney general screwed up
at the appellate level and then instead of going back to the trial court like he was instructed
to do he ran crying to the legislature to fix his problem for us and that's what we're trying
to do that's what the original bill was for and one last question um as a legislator
do you feel as though um yourself or the other legislators um have the right to spend the people's
money um and not have any idea how much of the people's money we're going to spend
um not be certain what the impact is going to be and not inform them in any way prior to that
we're going to spend their money the answer is no to all of those counts thank you no further
questions let me say this um i certainly qualify as a man
however i don't speak for all men
and regardless of how personal something may be if it means enough to you you will come
wherever that might be and speak for yourself or those that you love
so to say that we know this is happening i can tell you a whole lot of things that i feel like
are happening but there are many of you in the room that would look at me and say no
those things aren't happening we've been there before
um i stand in support of this of this motion i just don't see how in good faith
we can say that we represent the people and we agree to come in this building in this hall
and arbitrarily spend their money without ever asking them anything there are lots of other
things that we could spend the money on um not to know the amount of a fiscal note
not to have any idea how much something's going to cost you know it's funny because i've been on
dates before where that was the case i had no idea what this was going to cost
i was just crossing my fingers and open like heck i had enough in my pocket to take care of it
fortunately i never dated outside of outside of my income bracket so
i was always able to pay that bill however the income brackets of of our constituents
we may not be so in tune with so i stand in support of this motion um without even getting into how
i feel um about how wrong the bill itself is whatever we do in this body we should certainly do it
with the open knowledge of our constituency and the rest of the residents of Kansas in mind
and if they don't know i don't see how we can make decisions for them thank you
do any other members wish to speak to the motion the chair recognizes represent mcdonald
thank you miss thank you mr chair you know i i've knocked a lot of doors trying to get here
and and years with prior i've knocked a lot of doors trying to get other people here so that i got
the representation and on all my doors this this this topic has never come up but in most of my
doors in most of my doors property tax comes up and i just would like to give you all on the other
side of an aisle a chance to really take a step back and address property tax by taking this back
to committee and reconsidering it's very clear to me that the costs associated with this will fall
directly to our municipalities to our school districts to our community colleges to our universities
and i don't see any kind of um note in here about how we're going to allocate any money
to have this all happen right we're we're instantly going to have to have construction done on a
bunch of bathrooms i i think that this really is a chance for us to speak
to put our put our values behind what we're saying and put some action into it so if you really care
about property taxes you might want to consider approving this motion so that we can send it back
and work on it in committee if this is really our priority then we need to put some dollars with
it so that our cities our local taxpayers are not burdened with extra construction costs that
we're unexpected that will have to be in place within a month if i'm understanding this correctly
so i guess i have a quick question for the carrier of the motion to make sure that i'm
understanding correctly thank you for standing for questions so if we send this back to committee
there's nothing that would prevent the majority party from bringing it back and debating it at
any time correct that's correct so and if this were to go into effect municipalities school
districts community colleges universities even our state buildings would all be expected to
conform upon publication of the register that is correct yes okay at least that that is my
understanding is that law goes into effect in publication of the Kansas register and then
yeah everybody across the state of Kansas is required to comply failure to comply could be
twenty five thousand dollars initially up two hundred and twenty five thousand dollars and who
would pay that those fees i believe anybody that's in violation which includes the city's county's
municipalities yeah so they wouldn't only be on the hook for the construction costs if they didn't
hurry up and find magically fine construction crews to do this work they're going to be hit repeatedly
with violations that will cost more taxpayer dollars plus maybe thousand thousand dollars
a piece to individuals that report on those violations okay thank you very much i appreciate
that thank you um the only other point i have to make at this time is that at some point
democrats will be the majority party in this body
and i intend to stick around to see that out and make it happen and i would just encourage you
in all seriousness i would really encourage you to take a step back and look at how this looks
to the public you have cut them out of a fair amount of the conversation in this topic
with procedures that we all agreed to in the rules
there is no benefit to you to rush this through i would argue it benefits us on this side of the
aisle come campaign time when we can very clearly point out a blatant example of how
the GOP in this building prioritizes red meat issues rather than
bread and butter issues for our constituents right now the choice you make if you don't send
this back to committee for more work is very clearly raising property taxes on our constituents back
home clear as day if someone has an argument i would love to hear otherwise but i don't think
this is hard math people the lack of a fiscal note is on purpose my cities are not interested
in solving a problem that doesn't really exist so i'll be supporting this motion to send it back
and i would really hope that those of you in this room who really are fiscally conservative
would join me in being really careful with our taxpayer dollars because this is messy legislation
the the arbitrary rules and timelines that we have in this building are made by us
the appropriations that we make in the budget are made by us
this legislation is very costly
in our municipalities one of the only levers they have to raise and lower revenue is
free tax so really think twice before you make a decision here because i can promise you those
of us who are pretty active and defending vulnerable seats and and um going to be pretty aggressive
frankly in gaining numbers for those of you who are vulnerable on the other side i want to really
think carefully about this one thank you
does any other member wish to speak to the motion the chair recognizes representative neighbor
thank you mr chairman
you know we had a representative up here a little bit earlier that said if a woman heard
a man's voice in a stall it brought back memories i want to give you a little information
about what's wrong with this bill i have a niece she's trans she has a full beard full dark head
of hair all right she goes back and changes her driver's license to female guess what
she's going to be in that email restroom and that voice may return that's a problem
with the bill as it stands right now there there's nothing that says that's not going to happen
this is a young lady who from the time she could walk urinated standing up because she knew
within herself
yes i am sir thank you representative please keep your comments to the motion rather than
underline bill this is again retaliation and i say that it's retaliation in the money form
to our cities our municipalities our counties our school districts because it's a man
date upon printing in the register and i defy any of us here who have anything to do with city
or county government some of you have been county commissioners some of you have been city council
people to be able to turn a restroom around in that period of time and find that money in the
budget we're not paying for it we don't have a physical note we're expecting these entities
to pay for those changes where's the money where's the beef we are placing this as a
mandate on all of these which should have home rule
this is retaliation on the people we serve
remind members please keep your comments to the motion not the underlying bill the chair
recognizes represent moseley
thank you mr chairman i support this motion to bring it back send it back to committee
mostly because of the fact that as any of all of us want to protect women and children for one
we should be based on facts and not threats of our imagination and threats of mass hysteria
you are more likely to be assaulted by a clergy member than you are a trans person i think that
we should be making policies based off of fact thank you very much so let's bring it back to
committee do any members wish to speak to the motion the chair recognizes uh representative
honfries thank you mr chair i encourage you to vote no on this motion for reasons my colleague
from oletha said it beautifully but also for the reason everything was done according to the rules
we didn't do anything that was outside of what is possible so i would encourage you to vote no
we've had a good discussion about this bill do any other members wish to speak to the motion
seeing none representative osmond you may close on your motion
thank you very much mr chair i close and move my motion
you've heard the motion by representative osmond to refer sb 244 to the judiciary committee
all those in favor signify by saying aye
pose nay
ayes appear to have it the vision has been called the clerk will open the roll and you may vote
is every member had the opportunity to vote the clerk will close the roll and take the tally
85 or 35 having voted in favor and 85 against the motion fails we're back in the bill does anybody
wish to speak to sorry i apologize representative osmond thank you very much mr chair
I really thought we'd get out of here early today
why did i bring the motion up why did i bring all of this up
not me crying into my sleeve it's i wanted to make sure you were all aware of what's taken place
procedurally in the shenanigans that have happened to get us to this point i want to make sure the
public is aware of what took place to get us here and more importantly than this
we're not sports teams we're not here to rack up points for our side we're not here for the
cheers and the accolades from die heart bands who are do or die about their team in politics
the entire bill from start to finish was designed to minimize the public input
minimize legislative debate to skirt the rules so that one side could get a win at all costs of
decorum of how you all know the process should work you all know how the process should work
and if you believe you were right and just and if you stand
you can stand for reasonable discussion or else what else are we even here for
thank you very much mr chair do any other members wish to speak to the bill chair recognizes
represent car michael
thank you mr chair i rise in strong opposition to senate bill 244 i want to discuss a couple
of matters with you here today because i know my colleagues are prepared to discuss a number of
problems with this bill but i want to initially address the bill in the form that it was when
it was published and when the public did have notice of the bill and had an opportunity to be
heard those provisions are still in the bill those are the provisions that don't really have
anything to do with bathrooms they have to do with gender markers on driver's licenses
and in simple terms that means at least for most of us the m on my driver's license and maybe the
f on yours and so you understand what the bill was at least originally about before bathrooms
reared their head in the discussion it was based on a claim by the attorney general
that the Kansas Court of Appeals had committed serious error in fact the attorney general went
so far as to disparage three friends of mine chief judge or then chief judge Arnold burger
now chief judge Warner and judge hill and what the attorney general erroneously claimed
was that he had brought a lawsuit against the director of vehicles saying that the director
of vehicles was not following Kansas law with respect to changing M's to F's and F's to M
and he argued to the court that in essence all driver's licenses should bear the same letter
as the sex of an individual that was on their original birth certificate
and what he also asked was that any birth certificates that had been changed he somehow revoked
and he asked that any driver's license where there wasn't a match between an original birth
certificate and the M or the F on a driver's license be invalidated he said that was required
by a law we passed a couple years ago the status of the case at the time the bill reared its head
in the judiciary committee this year was that a preliminary a request for a preliminary
injunction had been granted by the district court in Shawnee county that matter had been appealed
to the court of appeals and it was heard by judges Warner Hill and Arnold burger
those judges looked at the record below in other words the evidence that was presented in the
district court in Shawnee county and those judges concluded that for purposes of a preliminary
injunction that the state had not met its burden to prove that there would be irreparable harm
unless the preliminary injunction was granted immediately now where did the misrepresentation
from our attorney general begin that's when he came to our committee and in my judgment insulted
professional integrity of three distinguished jurists one of whom I went to law school with
and what he said was that in violation of their oaths that these three judges had ignored his
evidence claim to us that there was that that he had proven his case to show irreparable harm
in part because he was the attorney general and had issued an opinion saying that there was
irreparable harm needless to say that didn't go very far in the court of appeals
but where the true insult to our court occurred was when the attorney general
failed to tell the committee about the testimony that was induced in the district court in Shawnee
county principally by witnesses called by the attorney general and I know my friend from garden
city will come and tell you that he has read the record but what he can't deny is that the
statement made by the attorney general and committee that the judges ignored his evidence it's just
flat out incorrect and the attorney general should have known it because if you take even a cursory
glance at the opinion of the court of appeals you will find that the court in excruciating detail
went through the testimony of each of the seven witnesses and demonstrated that none of their
testimony supported the attorney general's claim that there was some irreparable harm occurring in
Kansas because some people had an M on their driver's license and other people had an F
the court carefully examined the testimony of each of those witnesses and demonstrated how
not only did they not support the attorney general's claim they in fact
gave testimony contrary to the attorney general's claim and that applies to the law enforcement officers
who testified that applies to people from the division of vehicles who testified the simple fact is
that the attorney general once again failed in his burden of proof now I don't propose here this afternoon
now I don't propose here this afternoon or morning whichever it is to go through the prior instances
where that has occurred I'm sure we're all well familiar with prominent cases literally all over
the country that the attorney general has lost as well as cases in Kansas but what you need to
understand is that the court of appeals in this case did not on a final basis rule against the
attorney general's position what the court of appeals said was for purposes of a preliminary
injunction you failed to present credible evidence of an irreparable harm therefore the district court
was incorrect in granting that preliminary injunction that doesn't mean the case is over
the attorney general has the opportunity to try again to bring evidence at the actual trial of
the case to bring witnesses to correct the mistakes that he made at his motion for a preliminary
injunction but the attorney general despaired of the opportunity to present further evidence
instead he came here and made the same flawed arguments to the judiciary committee that he
made before the court of appeals which the court of appeals roundly rejected then even went so far
as to try to relitigate if you will the opinions of the court of appeals filed additional motions
in the case tried in essence to stop the order of the court of appeals from going into effect
but what happened the district court in Shawnee county last friday sanctioned him the sum of
$1 for what he had done in the case by filing a motion that was frivolous caused other parties
to bear expense and so even even the district court in Shawnee county has now recognized that
the attorney general is misguided in what he thinks the opinion of the court of appeals is
finally I of course would add that the Kansas Supreme Court read the opinion of the judges on
the court of appeals and said there's nothing that needs to be disturbed here and refused to hear
the attorney general's appeal so that's what brought us here it was an attempt by the attorney
general to cover up or paper over his embarrassing loss in the court of appeals by asking the
legislature to somehow counterman that so that was the posture that the bill was in i want you to
understand that if in fact the attorney general is right that if his evidence did prove his case
he has the opportunity to go back to the district court in Shawnee county and prove his case
bring his evidence let it be heard so that case is not over we need to be careful
about the legislature becoming the third branch if you will of the judiciary we need to be careful
about disappointed litigants coming to us and asking to re-argue their cases so that we can
decide them differently than the courts did. I don't think I might mention the attorney general
also claims that when the court of appeals disqualified Judge Watson at the district court
from continuing to hear the case the attorney general told us in committee that that was an
unprecedented action that the court of appeals had made that up out a whole cloth that there wasn't
precedent to support the court of appeals determining that a judge had prejudged a case and therefore
ordering that it be assigned to a different judge which is what the court of appeals did
the fact the matter is that that has been the law of Kansas long prior to this decision in fact the
case that was cited in the court of appeals opinion is in the matter of the estate of lense
2020 case by our court from our supreme court where ironically the supreme court of Kansas
disqualified three judges on the court of appeals from continuing to hear a case because the court
decided in that instance those judges had prejudged the case and disqualified them there are four or
five other cases that use the same doctrine in Kansas to disqualify judges below when they
prejudge cases so contrary to the attorney general's representation to the judiciary committee that
this disqualification of the district court judge was cut out of whole cloth and something
they made up on their own no it follows precedents in Kansas in fact a concurring opinion that was
signed on to by Caleb Stiegel you'll all recall Justice Stiegel was Sam Brownback's former general
counsel and Governor Brownback I believe's only appointment the state supreme court so that's where
the doctrine came from now that I've covered the boring for some and the interesting for others
procedural history of the case that brought us here I do feel compelled to address for just a
moment because I know that there are will be plenty of lights lit and other representatives
who make cases makes the case but our prior representative who described the circumstance
involving her niece and as I understand it now nephew is absolutely correct understand what this
bill says this bill says that if you are 40 years of age if you have hair on your face if you wear
boots if I'm not going to go back to an old song but if if you look like a man you walk like a man
you live as a man you may or may not have physical changes accomplished in your body to make your
body comport with what we typically identify as male that if you are on the Kansas turnpike
because the McDonald's is a private business you will urinate in the men's room
and I seriously doubt that that's going to cause any particular problem because transgender people
have been urinating in men's rooms for a long time but what this bill says if instead
you stop at the rest area on interstate 35 a public facility that the hairy faced male truck
driver will not go into the men's room heaven forbid no because he was had a gender identifier
on his birth certificate that said he was female because of that the hairy faced truck driver
dressed like a man whose voice sounds like a man who lives his life as a man is going to go into
the bathroom on interstate 135 and he or she is going to sit down at the stall next to your
granddaughter is that what you really want not only that when there are public facilities which
have locker rooms or the like that hairy faced man will be standing naked showering next to your
daughter that's what this bill requires it requires people who look like live and are in fact now
male to use women's facilities that what you want if you do I would suggest that you may have a
form of mental illness so I stand in strong opposition to senate bill 244 and I hope that
my colleagues will do the rational thing and leave things as they are thank you mr. chair
do any other members wish to speak to the bill chair recognizes representative steel
thank you mr. chair as a nurse my first obligation is simple do no harm as a school nurse my lens
goes further and is focused on student health safety and dignity every single child who walks
into a school building deserves to feel physically safe and emotionally secure that includes something
as basic and personal as using the restroom or the locker room restrooms are not political spaces
in a school they are private spaces and privacy matters deeply especially for children and adolescents
whose bodies are changing and who are already self-conscious I have walked alongside students
during some of their most vulnerable moments I have cared for girls navigating their first
menstrual cycle embarrassed and unsure at what is happening to their bodies I have supported
boys and girls managing medical conditions and I have worked with students who carry the weight
of horrific trauma these students simple routines as such as going to the restroom or using the
locker room can trigger anxiety and panic attacks for many of these children the restroom is not
just a convenience it is a vulnerable space where they expect a level of physical and emotional
safety adolescents are still developing a sense of identity and modesty and personal boundaries
they deserve environments that respect those boundaries without forcing them to negotiate
privacy in moments when they should not have to when privacy feels compromised anxiety increases
and avoidance behaviors increase I have seen students restrict fluids or avoid using the
restroom altogether which can lead to urinary tract infections dehydration in other preventable
health concerns colleagues we should not be add that we should be advocating for policies that
protect students safety uphold dignity and reduce unnecessary risk as leaders we are entrusted with
creating stable predictable environments where students can focus on learning rather than
feeling anxious or exposed maintaining sex separated restrooms and locker rooms based on
biological reality provides a clear and consistent safeguard for all students I ask for your support
on how substitute percent at bill 244 thank you do any other members wish to speak to the bill
the chair recognizes representative simmons thank you mr chair
well I wasn't actually going to share this until I listened to some of the earlier testimony
I'm a victim of sexual assault and never once never once have I thought to make it somebody
else's responsibility to manage my trauma I spent years in therapy I drained my savings to pay for
therapy I worked exceedingly hard to get to a place where I could do something like I am today
sharing it for the betterment of other people my assault her now works for I'm sorry my friends
across the aisle a republican member of congress and I regularly see him celebrating his professional
accomplishments while I had to move home I was assaulted within 30 days of starting my master's
degree in another state and it was incredibly difficult and I feel enormous sympathy for victims
of trauma that goes without saying but I do not appreciate my trauma it would be lovely if people
could stop speaking and listen if this is really about women's safety I do not appreciate my trauma
being used to justify legislation that we know will cause harm to people we don't know how much
money it's going to cost we should think about that but I'm saying right now respectfully I am
very much not okay with my trauma being co-opted to push legislation that has not been vetted
it's going to cost an enormous amount of money and that we know is going to genuinely impact
people's lives I feel a lot more fear from men in our community than I have ever felt from a
trans person here in this building as an intern as a committee assistant as staff and as a legislator
I have been sexually harassed more than you would believe so if we're going to talk about women's
safety we should address the real problem which is how women are treated not putting the spotlight
on one new member of our legislature because other people are uncomfortable with it I am
uncomfortable every single day but that is not anyone else's problem please do not support this
legislation and if you do so do not use victims of rape to do it does any other member wish to
speak to the bill the chair recognizes representative poskins
thank you mr chair you know body the first words that I heard when I walked into this hallowed
halls of of this building were unintended consequences I swear it leaks out of the walls
unintended consequences unintended consequences that's why I was so excited to see the efforts
of the good representative from atchison whose name by the way rhymes with evis not evis I just
want everybody to get that right and the good representative from garden city to form the
bipartisan local government caucus it got so much good press to including this quote bills were
being debated and it just felt like the effect it would have on local government wasn't being
fully measured and they identified at least 40 legislators with local government experience
in both of our chambers would the carrier the bill stand for questions
thank you so much representative so you know we've got this great resource it's just been
formed this year and I'm wondering if you consulted with this caucus to learn from their
experience about the effects on local government of this bill particularly the provisions of hb 24 26
okay i'm sorry what resource was that that you were talking about the bipartisan local
government caucus that was formed this year no and their interest in making sure that the body
understood the effect on local government of the bills that we passed here I know I wasn't aware of
it i don't know if i'm not invited well there's it's been covered a lot in the press and i can
i'll actually give that to you okay i'm on your way out okay so then my second question would be
will local governments have any opportunity to publicly weigh in on the provisions of
house bill 24 26 that have been inserted into the original bill now if we pass this bill it's all
government buildings that are owned were leased by the government right and the government
subdivision right so but the question was if local governments and like the league of municipalities
and so forth will they have an opportunity to weigh in on the impact to them of the provisions of
house bill 24 26 that were added to the underlying bill no the league is a they're not a government
entity but the municipalities no this is this bill is any government buildings that are owned
or leased by the government and the subdivisions of the government right i still maybe you're not
getting what the question is okay will those governments that are affected by it have the
opportunity to publicly weigh in on the impacts of the portion of the bill that was added with
hb 24 26 if we pass this bill the bill is passed so the answer is no local governments will not
have the opportunity to weigh in publicly on the effects of house bill 24 26 they can implement it
the way they would like to implement it but they will not get to weigh in on okay that that's great
oh wait i had one more if you don't mind i know um do we have it i think i might know the answer
to this but there is not a fiscal note that addresses the addition of hb 24 26 and so my question
that my representative from oletha kind of touched on do we know what the impact and what
costs this will add to local property taxes that our constituents will be paying i would love to
address that and i can do it when i close but i think we need to think about what do you mean by a
fiscal note because there is nothing in this bill where there has to be any new construction
there is nothing as far as infrastructure that has to be changed the only thing is existing
multi-person private spaces have to be designated as either male or female it might require a change
on your door but but it doesn't require anything to be built and so i just want the body to think
about what do you think the fiscal note might be on that it's it's a good question yeah i would
like to know and if there was an opportunity for a public hearing i think that perhaps
that would be part of it so thank you very much for answering my questions body unintended
consequences let's not do this i urge you to vote no on senate bill 244 and the fact that
we just formed this bike partisan local government caucus and one of the first things we do in the
first what two weeks is cut them out completely of their ability to weigh in on a bill that will
very much impact them thank you does any other member wish to speak the bill the chair recognizes
representative valuis
thank you mr chair i have an amendment
uh yeah the amendment appears short the clerk will read
i move to minhouse substitute for sp24 on page 10 following line 15 by inserting
new section seven sections one through six and amendments there two are declared severable
any provisions of sections one through six and the amendments there two or the application thereof
to any person or circumstance that is held to be unconstitutional invalid shall not affect the
validity of any remaining provisions of sections one through six and amendments there two with the
applicability of such provisions to any person or circumstance and by renumbering sections
accordingly representative do you wish to explain your amendment yes mr chair it is fairly straightforward
we put the severability clause into a lot of our our bills and in this case you know one would
expect because of all the issues that are being raised and because of all the interest groups
involved that there may be litigation on one or one or more parts of the the bill and so i think
it's good that we say that there's severability uh and the the declaration of of one section to be
invalid or unconstitutional doesn't affect the validity of the other i'm open for questions
does any member wish to speak to the amendment the chair recognizes representative car michael
excuse me my phone is talking to me for an absolutely unknown reason there we go
glad it didn't say anything offensive mr chair i rise in opposition to the amendment and i'll
make it brief the only reason you need a severability clause and a statute is if you think
parts of your statute are unconstitutional and will be overturned by the court severability is the
concept that even if part of the bill is found to be unconstitutional the entire bill does not go
down the court will sever the unconstitutional portions of the legislation from the constitutional
provisions if it is in fact able to do so so it's often referred to as what's known as a savings
clause because it saves your constitutionally infirm bill
oh i'm sorry one of my friends was talking on the phone there and i thought he was talking to me
so to say this is an attempt to save a constitutionally infirm bill
why does something like that happen well the reason is because you rush it through without
proper scrutiny you spring it on the committee literally without notice so the few lawyers we
have left in the legislature don't have a chance to to examine it and if this bill had followed
regular order or if this bill had been referred back to the committee then we could have heard
from the representative what portions of his amendment in committee he now believes are so
constitutionally suspect that we need a savings clause so i would urge you to reject this amendment
thank you mr chair does any other member wish to speak to the amendment the chair recognizes
represent mcdonald thank you mr chair i'm not really surprised to see this
amendment today because our let's just face it our attorney general has a really bad
track record and so we need to put a lot of these escape clauses and just to cover his ineptitude
at his job but like like my friend from which it all just said we're having to do this because
we're in a big hurry i fail to understand why we must shove everything through
when we hurry we make mistakes all of the deadlines that we make in this building are arbitrary and
self-imposed it might be an election year and that might be why we're getting out of here so quick
but i would argue that this is real legislation that impacts real kansans
let's be a little more careful with what we do so that we don't have to insert these clauses
and we actually produce good legislation thank you
does any other member wish to speak the amendment the chair recognizes representative osmond
thank you very much mr chair i echo the sentiments of the of my colleagues before me
the only reason that we're dealing with this amendment is because we rushed the process the
only reason that we're here debating it right now is because things got missed you know where we
can solve this if we just had another debate in the senate where we could have a hearing
and make the corrective actions and then come back and do a conference committee later on in the
session to rectify all of it that is a simple solution to this problem that apparently
we're incapable of doing so i rise in opposition to this amendment
does any other member wish to speak to the amendment the chair recognizes representative humphries
thank you mr chairman this would be a friendly amendment thank you
does any other member wish to speak to the amendment the chair recognizes representative car
thank you mr chair i was attempting to enjoy my lunch as i overheard this part of the debate
with the carrier of the amendment please stand for question
excuse me it's actually a motion not an amendment motion thank you for that clarification and brings
me to my point you sir um are an attorney is that correct i am and certainly i am not so
so what i would like to know is in layman's terms
if what some of the other attorneys have said are correct um or some of my other colleagues
why in fact are we bringing this motion if in fact we've got good legislation
um respectfully i disagree with some of the things your colleagues have said and when i close i'll
respond to those um this is a very common uh provision in our legislation um and quite frankly it doesn't
suggest that i have any personal issues with the constitutionality i just know that there are a
lot of interest groups supporting your side of the aisle that interested in the bill and they are
very litigious so they're likely to bring litigation and if one provision is deemed to be unconstitutional
then i want the rest of it to be uh say that's very common there's there's nothing
in particular unusual about this amendment thank you no further questions um you know i'll just say
that um my colleague stated that this is basically routine i would only contend that
this is session number four for me and in those four sessions routine it is not thank you
does any other member wish to speak the amendment i uh of the chair recognizes represent Vaughn
thank you mr chair just to summarize um if this passes um and this is litigated
which it will be because it's unconstitutional let this be proof that the proponents of this bill
know that it's unconstitutional too does any any other member wish to speak to the amendment
the chair recognizes represent but or a paisa
thank you um mr chair um with the bringer of the amendment stand for a question please
yes ma'am thank you um so my question is with the severability does this um preclude any claims
against the state is this preclude any claims against the state correct like does it take that
option out of people's hands who potentially may have to go and either change their driver's
license or be put out or anything along those lines doesn't prevent anybody from bringing a claim
you know if they think that's a valid claim okay perfect thank you so much thank you for
answering my question i greatly appreciate that i would like to remind all those who are listening
and viewing this um i understand there will most likely be um litigation brought for this
um particular bill in addition to that please be sure and uh aware make yourself aware of how
to bring a claim against the state thank you does any other member wish to speak the amendment
seeing none represent if you may close
mmm thank you mr chair yeah just for the record um i think there's been several suggestions from
some of the the speakers to the amendment that this suggests that i have some issue i have some
questions about this constitutionality and i just and i that i have some issues suggested that i
have some issues about its constitutionality and i emphatically say that's not the case
this is simply a recognition that as i said there are parties and opposed to this that are
very litigious and they're very likely to bring litigation and i think it's good that if only one
portion of the bill is deemed to be invalid or unconstitutional that the rest of the bill
survive and therefore i close you've heard the motion by representative lewis to amend all those
in favor signify by saying aye all opposed nay guys appear to have it the vision has been called
the kirk will open the role and you may vote
so every member has every member had the opportunity to vote the kirk will close the role
85 having voted yay and 33 voting nay the motion is adopted representative for still years
you
does any other member wish to speak to the bill the chair recognizes representative martinez
thank you body thank you mr. speaker i have an amendment
the amendment appears short the clerk will read
i move to amend house substitute for sp244 on page one by striking all in lines 18 through 36
by striking all on pages two and three on page four by striking all in lines one through 37
in line 38 by striking new and by renumbering sections accordingly on page one in the title
in line one by striking all after the semicolon by striking all in lines two through five
in line six by striking all before amending representative do you wish to explain your
amendment yes i do thank you
this amendment simply removes the bathroom language from house sub
sp244 to return the original bill which is defining the term gender to mean biological sex
at birth for purposes of statutory construction direct directing the division of motor vehicles
to invalidate and reissue driver's license to correct the gender identification on such
licenses and directing the office of vital statistics to invalidate and reissue birth certificates
the bathroom language expands the bill into public schools and other government facilities
where children use bathrooms with and without parents raising enforcement and liability
concerns buildings where this would apply would be public schools military buildings
museums court houses just to name a few and it is unclear to me if the bathroom language
is for clarity or safety but in reality it creates new risks especially for young children who do
not yet have a developmental ability to understand complex issues of identity science education
and common sense i'll tell us the same things that children's brains are still developing well
into their teenagers teenage years and beyond from a very young age we teach our children
about personal safety we teach them about boundaries about trusted spaces and about
listening to their instincts one of those trusted spaces are bathrooms when a man
a person who appears to be a man walks into a girl's bathroom and a young lady sees this she's
scared because she's been taught that that's a protected space that's a safe space and boys
aren't allowed in girls restrooms so what does that do that creates a situation where we have to
have a conversation that we may not be ready for and they probably if they're young enough
they're definitely not ready for so introducing these rigid rules into an environment of a child
a child cannot comprehend without context explanation or a choice can cause confusion fear
anxiety and even trauma even when no harm is intended this is the same reasoning many states
use when restricting children's access to certain online content or social media when kids are not
developmentally equipment equipped to process something it is our responsibility to proceed with
care not forced situations that they are not prepared to navigate striking this language
does not diminish safety in fact it strengthens it because this provision does nothing to stop
bad actors someone with malicious intent will not be deterred by a sign on a door or a line in
statute and last I checked it does not require a driver's license to enter a bathroom allowing
the bathroom language to be part of the original bill offers a false sense of security while
creating confusion in enforcement and placing parents and children and even building staff
in potentially impossible situations safety is about behavior not identity privacy should
protect everyone not create new vulnerabilities and not create situations where we have to have
conversations that our children aren't ready for we are at a time where whether we want to or
not whether we agree or not the truth is that America has grown and evolved our nation has
expanded we exist in many cultures ethnicities family structures and ways of being that diversity
is not a threat it is a reality of who we are our laws should reflect that complexity with care
humility and restraint especially when children are involved we can protect kids without
legislating fear we can respect privacy without inserting government into deeply personal spaces
striking this language keeps the bill focused on its original intent avoids unintended harm and
respects both families and children for those reasons I urge the body to support this amendment
to strike the bathroom provisions thank you mr. speaker does any member wish to speak to the
amendment the chair recognizes representative humphries thank you mr. chair i would ask the
body to vote against this this section is necessary in this bill why because women and girls should
not compromise their privacy safety and dignity in the most intimate spaces to accommodate men
because girls deserve to go to school and get their education without sacrificing their safety
and their well-being and the third reason we need this section is with because without it we have
no regulation in this state who may use which of the private spaces this is an integral part
of the bill and we need to keep it in so i would ask that you vote against the amendment
does any other member wish to speak the amendment seeing none represent martina as you may close
the amendment.
Once again safety is important for our kids that's why we need to maintain
safety i close close my and then my movement my thank you i close my amendment
you've heard the motion by representative martina's to amend all those in favor signify by saying aye
all opposed nay nays appear to have it division has been called the clerk will open the roll and
you may vote seeing ten hands a roll call is in order seeing fifteen hands a roll call is in order
sorry
As every member had the opportunity to vote, the role is still open, representative.
As every member had the opportunity to vote, 34 having voted, the clerk will close the role and take the tally.
34 having voted in paper, 83 against the motion fails.
Represent Martinez, you still have the floor. You wish to speak.
Okay.
I close.
Right. I what?
Do you wish to say anything else about the underlying bill?
No, I don't. Okay. Thank you. Thank you.
Does anybody else wish to speak to the bill? Chair recognizes representative Vaughn.
The second time. No.
For the first time. Sorry.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
I also want to start out by going back to process. As you heard when we worked this bill in committee, we had no idea that the bathroom bill balloon amendment was going to be brought.
It never had a public hearing.
We hardly had any time to read or analyze how it impacted the bill.
But most importantly, a question was never answered. And that question is, how is this possibly germane to the underlying bill?
When I asked that question in committee, the chair graphs for a response and I supplied the answer.
And that answer is that these are connected because they both discriminate against trans people.
They are both based on ignorance, fear, mongering and misinformation.
There is no actual problem that these bills solve. There is no existing harm that needs to be addressed.
And I'm going to give some examples of that, some of which have already been mentioned.
As was outlined with the court of appeals case, there is absolutely no evidence of any harm whatsoever that was provided to prove that allowing someone to change the gender marker on their driver's license or birth certificate.
In any way, impacts the ability of law enforcement to do their job or people to interact with government.
And this is a quote from the court of appeals decision.
They found that no one was able to bring forward any instance of any feared harm of misidentification of criminals in the last 16 years or even the potential that it could be a problem.
Instead, the evidence was overwhelming that there was no harm.
So in the 16 years that gender marker changes have been allowed, no harm has ever been identified by a law enforcement officer or anyone in the state that allowing gender marker changes has caused.
And I also want to highlight testimony that was provided by a Johnson County lieutenant from the Johnson County Sheriff's Office as part of this Court of Appeals decision.
He testified that in his 23 years of employment, he had not been made aware of any officer that had a problem with transgender person and their driver's license ever in his 23 years of working in the Johnson County Sheriff's Office.
This has been happening for at least 16 years, if not longer, and there are have been no issues identified with allowing people to change their gender markers on their driver's license and birth certificates.
In regards to the bathroom bill portion of this massive bill, I also want to highlight that research shows there is no link between trans inclusive bathrooms and crimes in bathrooms or locker rooms.
In fact, non discrimination laws protecting transgender people in these kinds of facilities have been around for a very long time.
In fact, since the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
And in that time, there has been no increase in public safety incidents in restrooms or locker rooms.
There is no problem. There's nothing that needs to be solved.
But what these bills do is cause real harm to transgender intersects and gender diverse people.
The ignorance misinformation and disinformation underlying the bill feed into hateful stereotypes that create real violence with showing your ID, for example, it should not be a dangerous act, but this bill would make it so.
It will force trans people to out themselves in multiple aspects of public life.
They already face extensive discrimination and hate based violence, just for being themselves.
If you think about the instances in which you need a legal document, a public ID, you need them to vote to get a job to go to school, even to get a library card.
In laws that put transgender people at a more risk of hate based violence for engaging in everyday actions like this would because we would be outing them in these various aspects of public life.
It means that transgender canons could miss out on those important parts of their life in order to protect their personal safety.
Bills like this literally intimidate trans people out of living their full lives because they are afraid of the danger in the violence that could potentially befall them.
In regards to the bathroom provision of this bill.
Studies have found that discriminatory bathroom and locker room policies are associated with higher rates of violence and assault towards trans people, not other people using the bathroom.
This is what creates violence for trans people in those public spaces.
There is no problem that this bill solves, but there is harm that it will cause.
Trans people just want to be left alone.
They just want to live their lives.
They want to live their lives free from government interference.
They want to have an ID that reflects their gender, their presentation.
As we heard in committee, they want an identification that is an artifact of their expression.
And you are taking that away with this bill.
Trans people just want to pee in peace like the rest of us.
And with this bill, you are taking the ability of them to do that away.
So, I want to highlight one additional thing here.
I apologize, we did not have a ton of time to get ready, so I am organizing my thoughts as I am speaking.
The other side of this, it is not just discrimination in public spaces, it's not just discrimination of allowing people to have driver's licenses that reflect their gender identities.
I don't know how closely you have read the bathroom bill, but it is also taking away spaces that are actively created to be inclusive for transgender diverse and intersex people.
So in the bathroom bill portion of this bill, it is making it so that gender neutral multi occupancy spaces are illegal.
So bathrooms that are gender neutral that have multiple stalls changing rooms that are designed to be gender neutral spaces that are intended to be gender gender neutral other than a single occupancy stall are illegal under this bill.
Kansas City International Airport bathrooms would be illegal.
The bathrooms at my favorite local brewery would be illegal.
The bathrooms that I know are in some of our local K through 12 schools to support and be inclusive that have multiple gender neutral stalls will be illegal.
And that is cruel. It is not just discrimination. This bill takes away spaces that are actively created to be inclusive for people who are gender diverse.
And I think it is important to talk about that.
This bill does allow for single occupancy gender neutral spaces. It does not require them.
And I think if we're going to take the ability away for trans people to use the bathroom and public spaces that that should be required. So I have an amendment.
The amendment appears short. The clerk will read.
I move to amend House substitute for SB 244 on page two in line 16 after the period by inserting the governing body or the chief administrative officer.
If no governing body exists of each public building shall establish a single occupancy restroom is described in subsection a 7 a on each floor of such public building, including any structure owned by such governmental entity that contains a restroom.
In line 22 by striking a and inserting additional also in line 22 by striking space and inserting spaces.
Representative, do you wish to explain your amendment?
Yes, thank you, Mr. Chair. So this amendment essentially does what I described. It is specific to restrooms. But.
If this were to go into the bill, then it would require that every public building shall establish a single occupancy gender neutral restroom on each floor of the public building so that.
People regardless of their gender identity sexual orientation or for any other reason people who may want to use a single occupancy bathroom will have access to one on every single floor of a public building.
And with that, I stand for questions.
Does anybody wish to speak to the amendment?
The chair recognizes representative Humphreys.
Could I ask a quick question of the bringer of the amendment?
Did you get a fiscal note for this amendment?
Is there a fiscal note for the underlying bill? Is that a no?
That was a question. Okay. Thank you.
Body, what I would like to point out is this amendment requires construction and building.
The fiscal note would be, I mean, I don't even know what this will do, but it requires Kansas or sorry, government buildings to build or provide single space restrooms.
The other thing is, there's no enforcement in this amendment.
So how would that work? What would happen there? So, of course, I'm asking you to vote this amendment down because I also want to point out the underlying bill, there is no requirement that anyone build anything.
There's not really, I mean, think about it, what might the fiscal note be changing the labels on doors, maybe, but the amendment would certainly bring a fiscal burden to the municipality.
So I ask you to vote no.
And then the other member wish to speak to the amendment. The chair recognizes representative Haskins.
Just checking in on you gave you that option a while back. Here I am again.
One more chance got the amendment. Now, I do find it interesting that fiscal note is now really important.
And that's a question here and that we can laugh at that because it's really not that funny that we don't know how things are going to cost.
So, but because we don't have a fiscal note for the first one, the argument that we should have a fiscal note for this has already been negated because we don't think it's important.
I want you to also listen to what the amendment is asking. The amendment is actually asking for us to be able to have the quality of life that all Kansans deserve and that they should be able to have.
Now, the whole signage thing or how much it's going to cost. Are you kidding me? The bill itself can't even justify how much it's going to cost.
How are we going to enforce it? Well, I guarantee you will probably have some vigilantes in the restrooms.
So, how are we going to force it? That doesn't seem to be a unique argument against it.
Folks, let's do what's right for Kansas. Let's support the amendment and let's move on. Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Does any other member wish to speak to the amendment? The Chair recognizes Representative Ballard.
Thank you very much.
Boy, I said there a long time. My father, this one, I have to say.
We all have to go to the bathroom. Some of us wait a long time and we're running to get there.
If you're going to limit the bathrooms, you got to at least provide one. I mean, that's just not just human. That's a necessary needed place.
We laugh and it's kind of funny, except it's not really. If you've had to go to the bathroom in a hurry and you don't have a place to go, you panic.
So, I don't understand why this should be a problem.
You know, and when I'm at it, appropriations, we're cutting.
We have to find so much money to cut, but yet we're spending money and no one is really addressing that.
And all my years of walking on doors and I have not on a few hundred doors. No one has ever asked me about bathrooms.
They've asked me about a lot of other things, but not about bathrooms.
I've been offered, if I've been out there a long time, would I like to come inside and go to the bathroom?
And a couple of times I said, yes, thank you very much.
But you know, I'm making light of it, but boy, I tell you, my blood pressure is up.
So, I would look at this in terms of bathroom choices over the years. I have addressed those many times.
I cannot and I will not support any discrimination against another human being.
Anyway, shape or form. And for those of you that know me, you know, I stay true to that.
I would protect any of you if anybody was discriminating against you.
But when we get down to bathrooms, that even should not be an issue.
So, I would simply say to you, if this was really a big issue,
I would have allowed people in Kansas to weigh in on it.
And all the years they've never mentioned it.
Representative, could you please stay on the motion to amend, please?
Yes, thank you. Thank you for keeping me on track because I was really getting upset.
But I would really say to you, bathrooms seriously,
if you're going to take it away from them on one place,
do the right thing and allow one to be someplace else.
For that reason, I support this amendment because it's the human thing to do,
but it's also the legal thing to do.
And you think of yourself when you have to go, you have to go.
Thank you very much, Mr. Chair.
Does any other member wish to speak to the amendment?
Seeing none, Representative, you may close on your amendment.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Practically speaking, single occupancy bathrooms are often unavailable, inconvenient,
or inaccessible.
And as a government, if this legislature is going to force transgender people
to use private bathrooms simply because they're trans,
we sure as heck better have one available on every single floor of every single government building.
And that is why I brought this amendment.
So I move my amendment.
You've heard the motion by Representative on to amend all those in favor,
signified by saying aye.
All opposed, nay.
Nose appear to have it.
Division has been called.
The clerk will open the roll and you may vote.
Not seeing 15 hands, roll call is not in order.
Seeing 15 hands, a roll call is now in order.
Is every member have the opportunity to vote?
The clerk will close the roll and take the tally.
Does any member wish to change their vote?
Representative Schlingen-Sleepen votes aye.
Any other?
Representative Anderson votes no.
Representative Van Houden votes no.
And Representative Kessler votes no.
Representative Essex votes no.
Any other changes of vote?
Seeing none, the clerk will close the roll and take the tally.
36 having voted in favor and 85 against the motion fails.
Representative Vaughn used to have the floor.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
I think the failure of that amendment proves what this bill is really about.
It's not about clarifying anything.
It's not about statutory alignment or whatever.
This is about discriminating against trans people.
This is about making it impossible for them to use public spaces.
And if we can't even make a simple accommodation, like ensuring there's a bathroom that they
could use on every single floor of a government building, I think that proves my point.
The reality is that trans people are significantly more likely to be victims of violent crime
than the rest of the population over four times more likely per recent research.
They are the ones who will be harmed by this policy.
They are the ones who are harmed by the policies that this legislature keeps passing to take away their rights.
And I just want to highlight that because here we are again.
First, this legislature took away trans kids' ability to play sports.
Then it took away their ability to access health care.
Now you are taking away trans-cansons' abilities to be in and use public spaces.
You are taking away their identities, their identities on their driver's license and their birth certificate.
And most importantly and most shamefully, you are taking away their voice.
You are taking away their ability to voice opposition on this bill and how terrible it is.
And to that I say shame on you.
Does any other member wish to speak to the bill?
The chair recognizes Representative McDonald.
Thank you Mr. Chair.
I really appreciate the opportunity to get up and visit with you all a little bit more about this bill.
In legislative modernization committee this morning we had a really good conversation about testimony.
How we involve the public in being able to weigh in and make informed decisions to inform our decisions.
We talked about ways that we get in the way of the public being able to testify in a convenient and understandable way.
We talked about ways we could be more transparent.
We talked about ways we inadvertently keep them out of the loop.
We talked about ways that we could make things better here.
And this my friends is not the way we do it.
Again we are rushing through.
We could have taken the time that this sort of debate deserves.
And I would argue we're going to take the time today whether we all like it or not.
But in committee we could have really taken the time to sit down to listen to each other for understanding.
Not for rebuttal.
Not to score campaign points or get big donors to give us some attention.
Not because we have a convention coming up this weekend and we need something to talk about.
We need to come with a win.
But really because we want to sit down with each other in a spirit of cooperation finding real solutions to problems that real Kansans are facing.
I read somewhere that this driver's license drama really only impacts about 500 Kansans.
I started to think a little bit about how much time and money we've spent on this topic in this building over the last few years.
My friend from Olathe mentioned earlier that this has been really argued years and years before.
And I kind of find that a little insulting because not all of us were here years before.
The conversations about bathroom bills and sports and even healthcare decisions.
Those things deserve a real conversation with the people here today who will be making these decisions.
Now while some of you have been here a long time, I really do appreciate that institutional knowledge that you bring.
But when you dismiss those of us who have not been here very long, when you roll your eyes and say
we already hashed this out years ago.
This is old news.
Times change.
Clearly people change.
People come in and out of this building and there have been many people sitting in your chair before you.
And there will be many people God willing sitting in your chair after you leave.
The decisions we make here, the processes we make, we put into place, they're important.
And cutting the public out in the way that you have here today.
I would argue it's really unethical and unprofessional.
Reeks of a lack of transparency.
Seems to me kind of desperate.
When you feel like you can't let the public weigh in and you just need to shove it through.
I realize we're going to have a blue wave this year and I can understand why some of you might want to double down
and triple down on past campaign promises.
This may seem like a Hail Mary to get you a little bit more momentum going into campaign season.
But recycling this feeds division, fear, polarization.
When we could be seriously coming together and solving some real problems for real Kansans.
When I knock doors in really nice neighborhoods, I have people confiding in me.
I cannot afford my kids soccer this year.
My parents just moved back in with me.
I can't afford to put them in a nursing home.
I can't afford the care they need each day while I'm at work.
My wife can't work because we've got to pay for child care and she doesn't make enough to cover child care.
These are real issues that we could be focusing on because we have been given that power by the people who sent us here.
Yet today we're banging the same old drum.
We say with one out of one side of our mouth, we care about financial decisions that we make for taxpayers with their money.
Yet we can shove something like this through without a fiscal note.
The carry of the bill mentioned something about how there's no infrastructure that has to be changed.
That's not the way I read it.
And when I've talked to attorneys in my caucus, that's most certainly not the way they read it.
If you intended to not have to do any construction, why was that not written into this bill?
Why are you all not bringing an amendment to say no construction necessary?
If it's as simple as sticking a piece of paper on a door on a government building, policies can do that.
Do we really need a statute to do that? We do not.
And by the way, why can't we pass clean bills in this building?
There is no need for us to be bundling some driver's license law because Chris Cobuck has batted his job into some rehashing of a bathroom bill.
I don't really understand why we need to be putting two divisive issues in one bundle without giving the public a proper chance to vet it,
shoving it through so that in a month's time, there's so much ambiguity here.
How are jurisdictions going to figure out exactly what you mean other than through a lawsuit?
In Olayza School District, you know how many buildings the school district owns?
58 buildings in my Olayza School District.
I also represent Blue Valley School District. Do you know how many buildings they own?
39 buildings.
Maybe some of you represent Shawnee Mission School District, 51 buildings.
The Soto School District, 14 buildings and growing, by the way.
Gardner, 11 school buildings, Spring Hill, 13 school buildings.
That's just some of the districts in Johnson County.
Now, I know that a lot of you feel like in Johnson County, we live in the land of plenty where money is, you know, no big deal,
but that's not our reality in our school districts.
We have to pass bonds to build new buildings.
When we build new buildings, we try to do so with the latest infrastructure in mind.
We try to make sure that we're using the best practices, like at the Kansas City International Airport,
where they have one bank of bathrooms, private stalls, but it's coed, because it doesn't matter when you shut the door.
Nobody needs to be in your pants or in your business of what's in your pants.
Now, my friend from Manhattan, she mentioned earlier that we want to make sure and do no harm.
She said that this bill is important because of safety, that we owe everyone dignity.
Emotional security is really important, that restrooms are not political spaces.
They're private spaces.
And for those of you who aren't listening, let me repeat myself.
My friend from Manhattan said, we should do no harm.
Safety is important.
Dignity.
Emotional security.
Restrooms are not political spaces.
They are private spaces.
They're private for all of us.
It is hard enough for transgender teenage girls to face extra stigma.
My friend from Manhattan is a nurse, a school nurse, and she has talked about how she has helped young women going through their first mental cycles.
Imagine this.
We have denied hormone blockers for children who are struggling with their gender identity.
So not only are they struggling with normal puberty, they aren't even able to delay puberty long enough to figure out what's happening with their bodies.
We've denied them health care.
We're putting them through more trauma, hurting their dignity, refusing to give them a private space to just go to the bathroom.
Imagine your body revolting and menstruating when you feel like that is a foreign thing when you don't feel like you fit in your body.
And we as adults are coming in, traumatizing these children further.
Disregarding their safety, their dignity, their emotional security.
We are doing them harm.
Again, like my friend from Manhattan said, restrooms are not political spaces.
They are private spaces.
Other friends have already mentioned the increased prevalence of assaults on transgender individuals.
And I remember someone early in this conversation mentioned trauma that women go through when women are attacked.
Imagine being attacked in a sexual way.
Whether you're transgender or not, it's trauma.
And when you put trans people in a space where they stand out, they're inviting, it is inviting, abuse and trauma.
Now let's talk a little bit about education. Can we do that?
I'll wait.
Seems like private conversations are...
Representative, please continue.
I'd love for people to hear my voice.
My friends in the education community, we all want our kids to get a good education, correct?
We talk a lot about dollars need to go to the classroom, right?
That's what I hear all the time.
Why are we spending money renovating bathrooms in school districts and school buildings to solve a problem that does not really exist?
I have a son who has long hair and he made a decision when he was about seven years old, but he was going to have long hair.
And I thought, you know what, he's seven.
Let's let him grow his hair out while he's young, and then when he's a grown up, I can have him be a clean-cut guy.
It just didn't work out that way. That long hair has become part of his identity.
But he has the misfortune of looking exactly like me.
And before he could grow a full beard of facial hair, very, very often, when we would go out to dinner, he would be misgendered.
People would say, what can I get you ladies to drink? What can I get you ladies to eat?
And he didn't worry much about it because he could see how someone might misinterpret his gender.
But as a seven-year-old, an eight-year-old, a ten-year-old, he didn't really think much about it.
My worry as a mom, when you all started passing these bills about bathrooms, is that my son would go into the bathroom,
and a grown man would say, what are you doing in here, little girl?
It proved to me that you're a boy. What is the fixation with what's in people's pants?
It is creepy that people focus so much on what is in children's pants.
Embarrassing. It's an insult to this room. It's an insult to this body.
I'd like to go back for a minute to my concern about construction.
There is no fiscal note, and there is no allotment of money that's been given to this effort.
And although I know that the carrier of the bill continues to say there will be no construction involved,
forgive me, but I just don't see how that's possible, so I have an amendment.
The amendment appears short. The clerk will read.
I move to a Menhouse substitute for SB244 on page two, following line 22 by inserting three.
A governmental entity shall have four years from the effective date of this act to complete any remodeling
or reconstruction of any public building owned by such governmental entity that is necessary to comply with the provisions of the subsection.
Government entities shall not be in violation of this section with respect to any such public building during such four year period.
Representative, do you wish to explain your amendment? Yes, sir. I think I do.
So my stepdad was in construction, and I know that nothing in construction happens overnight,
and it's become pretty clear that whatever we do today, it's going to be enacted in about a month.
I don't know if you guys have had any construction done lightly, but it's very hard to get anybody to even come give a bid,
much less show up and do the work. So I think it's only fair if we're going to put this upon our municipalities,
our school districts, our community colleges, our cities, our colleges that we need to give them some time.
So my amendment would just give all government entities four years from the date of publish to complete any remodeling
or reconstruction of any building that's owned by the government.
And I think this is necessary because in our country right now,
we've really been cracking down a lot on immigration.
And I've noticed that a lot of my friends who are builders are having a harder time staffing their crews.
So that's just going to add to more trouble as far as trying to get this construction done in a timely fashion.
I know that in Johnson County, we have a lot of people there in the construction industry,
but I can only imagine when you live in a small town, it might be hard for you to get all of the trades involved,
the plumbing, the electrician, the tile workers, all of that to show up and get your school bathroom remodeled in a month.
So I'd like for us to give our municipalities a four-year window to get this construction done,
make sure that any litigation that happens surely in four years, it'll be all played out.
But this won't be an immediate cost on any existing buildings owned by the government.
Happy to stand for questions.
Does any member wish to speak to the amendment? The chair recognizes Representative Humphreys.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. I'm a little perplexed by the amendment,
because I just want to read from the bill that says that this subsection,
which is amended here,
this subsection shall not be construed to prohibit a governing body or chief administrative officer
from establishing a single occupancy private space.
So the bill says if an entity wants to do a single occupancy private space,
they may, that would be totally their choice.
This bill has nothing in it that says that they must comply that they have to do it.
And the amendment says that they would have four years to comply with the provisions of this subsection.
The subsection doesn't require anything to be built.
So I would obviously ask that you vote down the amendment. Thank you.
Does any other member wish to speak to the amendment? Seeing none, Representative, you may close on your motion.
I guess I would just argue that if this bill truly does not require construction,
I think it should have come out and said that.
And if that's so, then it won't hurt for you to vote yes on my amendment, because we'll make sure that our municipalities are school districts,
our colleges, our community colleges are not charged any undue costs associated with any construction as a result of this bill.
I close.
You've heard the motion by Representative McDonald to amend all those in favor signify by saying aye.
All opposed nay.
Nays appear to have it.
The vision has been called. The clerk will open the roll and you may vote.
Seeing 15 hands, the roll call is in order.
As every member had the opportunity to vote.
The clerk will close the roll and take the tally.
Does any member wish to change their vote?
Seeing none with 36 voting in favor and 86 against the motion fails. Representative McDonald, you still have the floor.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
This is the first amendment I've done without messing up. So thanks for sticking with me on that.
I can't can't argue with you.
You know, it's pretty clear that the writing is on the wall for this and and I just want to give you all a last a last chance to.
Consider the choice you're making here.
The choice you're sending.
The choice you make sends a message to Kansans.
Do you focus on issues that.
Add to division that vilify people.
That stereotype people who are different than you.
You do not have to understand something to be compassionate about it.
This is your chance to take government out of people's bedrooms out of their bathrooms out of their business.
My momma said you need to worry about yourself.
My mom said don't go trying to solve problems that aren't even real.
I just want to remind you also that we're soon going to be on the world stage.
With the World Cup coming Kansas is going to be in the spotlight.
Provisions like these are going to send signals to companies that Kansas focuses more on unnecessary and divisive issues in language.
Then becoming a welcoming place where people want to visit, live, work and play.
In Kansas we try to be good neighbors.
We try to take care of each other.
I understand that compassion is a short supply sometimes.
But I would just like to appeal to you and your humanity.
This is not necessary.
And for my friends across the aisle, I'm guessing this is going to pass, but you don't have to be complicit.
Please do the right thing and vote no on this bill. Thank you.
Does any other member wish to speak to the bill? The chair recognizes represent Stog still.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Despite the protest stations of the peace loving leadership in the Department of War.
We've had many and continue to have many transgender men and women serving patriotically and honorably in the United States military.
In light of that, I have a few questions for the carrier of the bill.
I apologize for having to ask these questions here. I would have preferred to have done it in committee before your committee, but that wasn't afforded me the opportunity.
First question I had, how would this impact military bases in Kansas?
They're federal.
And so this is a state law, right?
So they I don't believe we have jurisdiction over our federal buildings.
Do they have the same laws about transgender bathrooms on at Fort Riley and Leavenworth or spaces and so on that we would have in the rest of the state?
I don't know.
So transgender military personnel would have to have one set of laws that they have to follow on our military bases and another set of laws possibly as they go off base.
And also the same in public buildings.
Because that's different. This is only about government buildings.
Do we have do we have any state buildings on any of our military bases?
I don't know.
That would have been something I would have liked to know. How about the Kansas National Guard? How does this apply to them?
Same, I suppose.
I don't know.
Federalized at some point.
And at some point we would talk about it, I suppose.
And how about military recruiting facilities that are being used in state office buildings and so on?
Are the buildings owned by the government?
Awesome.
So, but there are federal employees, federal military employees.
Yeah. So this bill is about government buildings that are owned or leased by the government.
Okay. So if they're recruiting officers and so on on these facilities and they're in a state building, they have to ignore the laws that govern them when there are military bases because of Kansas laws while they're in recruiting kids to join the military.
I think they just have to look at what's on the door and accordingly do that.
What about tourists traveling across Kansas, not knowing the laws? What happens if they're stopped or what happens if somebody confronts them in a bathroom?
I know like when you're coming in from Colorado, it's legal to have recreational marijuana there, but we've had Coloradans stopped in Kansas for not following Kansas law.
Would tourists be subject to arrest and prosecution if they didn't follow Kansas law on our bathrooms?
So this is not about a crime.
This is about a complaint could be filed to the government entity and it would be investigated.
The government entity would actually have three days to cure the violation if it was under them.
Otherwise, a complaint could be made. There is a private cause of action, but at the most, it's a misdemeanor.
I mean, we're not talking about someone being arrested.
There's a lot of, I mean, in the bill, it goes into great detail what the enforcement is.
Okay.
Thank you. Appreciate it.
My constituents will hate this bill and they will certainly even more hate the process that it's gone through to get here before the members of this House of Representatives.
My constituents overwhelmingly support LGBTQ rights.
And they also expect to have the right to come to Topeka and express their opinion either verbally or in writing. They had neither.
Talk about, I guarantee you, I have never voted on a bill that has a fiscal note that reads blank.
And you can say, well, this is not going to cost anything. This is going to be cheap. This isn't going to be expensive. This isn't going to cause problems in our construction industry or anything.
Well, if that's the case, why did they leave it blank?
That leaves it open for interpretation. That leaves it open for anything.
I think we are absolutely beyond our scope when we vote for a bill that has the potential for millions of dollars potentially in building costs and so on.
And we vote for it because the fiscal note is blank.
This is money and time that we should be spending on debating property tax reduction.
This is time and money we should be spending on how do we fund special education in the state of Kansas, not this.
This is the kind of legislation that will hurt our state, our counties, our cities, our school districts, our colleges and our universities and the ability to to attract students to Kansas and businesses to Kansas.
I can tell you after having worked with the high tech industries for eight years in this state and in Missouri.
This is the kind of legislation that discourages those kinds of companies from coming to Kansas.
And if you don't believe me, call some legislators in North Carolina and see how well that worked out for them when they started doing this kind of legislation.
My constituents sent me up here to talk about property taxes to talk about public education to talk about public health. How do we make life speed life better for people in Kansas.
Not to discriminate against certain people in the state of Kansas who have done absolutely nothing wrong.
And I guarantee you my constituents will remember this bill and remember this process from now right up through November 3, 2026.
Thank you, Mr. Speaker.
Any other, does any other member wish to speak the bill?
The chair recognizes representative Schlingen Seepen.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
Colleagues, I rise because once again, we have a bill that my mind is part of the politics of polarization.
Politics of polarization, I think serves only one point.
We don't want to get things done that people need to have done because of ideological clashes.
You create all kinds of problems that don't exist in order to prey on the fears of people about all kinds of things rather than trying to allay fears, create unity and deal with policy issues that really matter.
When it comes to LGBTQIA rights and to those of our fellow trans citizens, I'd like to say that I'm very proud of my congregation, the first congregational church in Topeka, that has visited this issue in its own building,
and that has removed all gender designations from the doors because we don't need them.
There's no one feels threatened because we try to be an inclusive church and we try to understand each other, and we work very hard at trying to understand each other.
Because otherwise, what happens is that we get bathroom bills and we go back to times when bathrooms and bigotry seem to have not only been a literative, but reality.
Why do we think that putting targets on people's backs is okay?
If we understood the reasons that we put trends, people in the crosshairs of our policy constantly in this body, at least over the four years I've been here, in one form or another, we realized why we really did that, we wouldn't be bringing bills like this.
But either we don't realize it, that what we're really responding to are the fears we've created and maybe even believe in ourselves.
In fact, the evidence tells a very different story.
Trans-Cansans are not a threat to anyone, but there are a lot of people in Cansans who will be embolded by this kind of legislation and other kinds of legislation to harass transgender people, and it's happening already in our state.
My district stands firmly behind the trans community.
My church stands behind the trans community.
I know it takes work to get to that place.
I've pastored my church for 25 years now, going on 26.
And we worked very, very hard to be an inclusive church.
And it wasn't just saying we're inclusive and putting a sticker on the door that says everybody's welcome.
It was a process of everybody from age 96 down to five years old learning what we're talking about and understanding who that affects in our community and why we should care about each other anyway.
Because we don't believe that people are labels.
We believe that people are people.
Building relationships is the best way to combat this kind of generalized bigotry.
I asked myself the question with regard to this bill.
What happens when the hairy at birth female that my distinguished colleague from Sedgwick spoke to earlier is in the women's bathroom and someone files a complaint because they feel unsafe?
Well, what's going to happen then is a process that could lead to significant fines.
And it's going to create a witch hunt, which is what all kinds of motivated bills like this ultimately lead to.
They put targets on people's backs, verbal targets, and then people out there who aren't as discerning.
Maybe you don't have the kind of filters that we expect the civilized society feel they can take matters into their own hands.
So, with that I have an amendment.
It appears short the clerk will read.
I move to amend house substitute for SB 244 on page four in line 16 after H by inserting it is a violation of this section to make a false complaint either to the attorney general under subsection E or to a governing body or chief administrative officer under subsection G.
Any person who commits a violation under this subsection shall be subject to the notice provision under subsection G1.
Any person who commits a second violation of this subsection shall be subject to the civil penalty provisions of subsection G2.
Any person who commits a third or subsequent violation of this subsection shall be guilty of a class B misdemeanor.
And by redesignating subsections paragraphs sub paragraphs and clauses accordingly.
Representative, do you wish to explain your amendment? Yes, thank you, Mr. Chairman. In short, what this means is that if someone makes a false report, they are subject to the same penalties that are being imposed on those who would be found in the wrong bathrooms.
This basically creates a situation in which people who think that they are part of some kind of posse to solve problems, nobody wants solved that they're going to have to pay a penalty for doing so.
And with that, I move my amendment.
Does anybody wish to speak to the amendment?
Any other questions.
The chair recognizes Representative Lewis.
So appreciate your proposed amendment.
I'm wondering if you looked at whether or not we already have something in an all law for filing a false report with law enforcement.
I don't know that we do, but I assume by the question that we probably do.
Quite frankly, I don't, I would guess that we do, but I don't know either. That's why I'm asking if you check to know that. I don't know that. Okay. All right.
Thank you. Thank you.
Does any other member wish to speak to the amendment?
The chair recognizes Representative Humphries.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I would say this is an unfriendly amendment. Thank you.
Does any other member wish to speak to the amendment? Seeing none, Representative Schlingen, you may close.
Well, I think an unfriendly amendment belongs with an unfriendly bill.
And with that, I close.
You've heard the motion by Representative Schlingen seeping to amend all those in favor signify by saying aye.
I'll oppose nay.
Nays appear to have it.
Division has been called. The clerk will open the roll and you may vote.
Seeing 15 hands, the roll call is in order.
As every member had the opportunity to vote.
The clerk will close the roll and take the tally. Does any member wish to change their vote?
Seeing none with 36 voting in favor and 81 against the motion fails. Representative Schlingen seeping, you still have the floor.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
I just want to say that.
I just find this very disappointing.
They were here once again, putting people who are already very, very vulnerable in a more vulnerable position.
It makes me sad.
It makes me sad as a pastor, as a politician, as a human being.
And all I can say is, if someone's ever near 17th and Collins, 1st Congregational Church has bathrooms for you.
So, thank you, Mr. Chairman. Thank you.
Does any other member wish to speak to the bill? The chair recognizes Representative Chuck Smith.
Thanks, Mr. Chair.
You know, as a geometry teacher, one of the things I thought my kids was listened.
So, I've listened to everybody and took some notes on what I disagree with.
First off, have you been to a Kansas City Chiefs game?
I guarantee you, in the men's bathroom, there is no private space.
I guarantee you, when they build that new stadium in the men's bathroom,
I promise you there's not going to be a stall for everybody that needs to go to the bathroom.
It's not going to be there.
My friend said to me, I hope both sides can work together.
Guys, if we can't agree on this, we can't work together on almost anything.
This is pretty sad, I think.
Cost?
You know, we shouldn't have left the blank. We should have said zero.
There's no cost.
The men go to the men's bathroom, the women's go to the women's bathroom.
And if it's a single unit, wherever it goes in, locks the door, nobody else can come in.
That's easy.
Driver's license.
The only time I ever get my driver's license out is when I go to the airport.
And they're not going to stop me from going through when they looked at it
and say, yeah, let's you go ahead.
They're not going to stop me.
I heard one of my friends said the quality of life.
I have three beautiful daughters and a beautiful girlfriend of 49 years.
And I want to give them the quality of life also.
And I tell you what, if they're in the bathroom and a man comes in,
you have taken that away from them.
They deserve that quality of life also.
Like I say, it's, you know, they say we rush this bill.
This is my eighth year.
And I remember talking in some ways about it for all eight years.
Maybe not exactly like this, but something about like this for eight years.
That's not new.
We didn't rush it.
Please give my girls the quality of life they deserve.
Thank you.
Does any other member wish to speak to the bill?
The chair recognizes representative Lewis for the second time.
Mr. Chair, I have an amendment.
The amendment is extremely short.
The clerk shall read.
It is a simple amendment.
The bill as presented.
Provides that notwithstanding the provisions of B through G, which require that the.
Government entity designate bathrooms as one sex or the other multi.
Multi occupancy.
It goes through some exceptions.
And one of those is that a child who is under 12 years of age may enter a multi occupancy
private space designated for use only by individuals of the opposite sex.
If accompanied by an individual caring for such child.
And my amendment just moves that age from instead of the current 12 under 12 to under nine.
Is there anybody wishing to speak to the amendment?
The chair recognizes representative Carmichael.
Mr. Chair, I rise in opposition to the amendment.
The hallmark of a poorly prepared piece of legislation is a series of floor amendments.
This bill was rushed into the committee.
It wasn't given a full opportunity for consideration by the members of the committee because we literally didn't see it until.
Moments. I mean, after the amendment made been made in committee, we never had a chance to really look at it.
But surely the author of the amendment took time to look at what he was bringing to the house judiciary committee.
But it would appear that mistakes were made.
Omissions were made that were legislating on the fly.
Citizens of Kansas.
Is there better than a knee jerk bill? Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Does any other member wish to speak to the amendment? The chair recognizes representative Michael.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
I stand in strong opposition to this amendment.
When I read this bill, I saw this language about children younger than 12 and I thought.
Okay, at least somebody thought about that provision.
Lowering that age to nine. It's incredibly worrisome.
I have a son who is going to turn nine in three weeks.
And so if this were to go into effect, that means when I take him to Alan Fieldhouse or the KU Stadium or wherever in three weeks,
I just have to send him into the men's room unaccompanied if my husband is not with me.
Whereas if we reject this amendment, I will still have the option when I feel like I want to escort him into the women's room to be able to do that until he turns 12.
I strongly oppose this amendment.
Is there any other member wishing to speak the amendment? The chair recognizes representative Poskin.
Thank you, Mr. Chair, to the point that both of my previous colleagues made.
If this part of the bill had been vetted properly, had a public hearing.
Parents of all ages of children could have commented on that and would have been able to tell you what representative from the representative from Lawrence just did.
That is too young and I'm the mom of seven and grand parent of.
Or and a question to the bringer of the amendment. If he will stand for a question.
Thank you represent welcome. So when I just said that a question popped in my head. What about grandparents?
Well, when I take my child to.
The stadium or to, you know, Alan Fieldhouse.
And they're nine. Can I go in with them? Yes, if you're caring for such child hearing for such child. Thank you. Yeah, you're welcome. Okay.
I still stand opposed to the amendment and we really should have vetted this and let parents tell their stories.
Is there anybody else? Is there any other member wishing to speak to the amendment? The chair recognizes representative McDonald.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. Would you be willing to stand for a question?
Thank you so much.
I stepped out to go to the restroom. So I may have missed when you said this. So if you'll indulge me. Sure.
Exactly what problem would your amendment solve?
Like what is what is the reason for you bring in the amendment? Well, the original bill said that if a child under the age of 12 is being cared for that the adult caregiver can take him or her into a space that's not designated for his biological sex.
And we're moving that down to nine or under under nine. And I think that thinking was from talking to colleagues that, you know, the age at the age of nine.
It's unlikely that somebody is going to need to be accompanied into a bathroom. And at that age, they become becoming aware of sexual differences.
So to be clear, if someone is 10, but their grandparents are with them, they can't go to the bathroom with their grandparent if their grandparents the opposite sex. Yes, that's right.
Okay, thank you.
I was raised with sisters. And when when they said how to ultrasound and every time they said it's a boy, I was just freaking out a little bit because all we have in our family is girls and I had to figure out how to do this thing to be employment.
And one of my biggest challenges was the bathroom situation. And I'm always so grateful to find a family bathroom where the whole family can get in there with a double stroller and, you know, all of that, all of the equipment, the diaper bags.
But that's not always the case. And so I feel like this amendment makes this bill even more dangerous somehow.
As the mother of two boys, they were there about 13 months apart. Very, very often I was juggling toddlers running, which, you know, different directions.
And I can't imagine when I think back to my son, like I said, he grew his hair out when he was about six, eight. When he was nine, he looked like a girl. I'm just going to say it.
When he was 10, he certainly looked like a girl. And because of the way I choose to raise my children, they're very aware of sexual differences. They know a lot about human reproduction because that's my right as a parent to make sure that they understand good touch, bad touch.
Yeah, they're on the lookout for people who might be nefarious, but also it's intimidating for a grown adult to come into a bathroom and boss around a kid, even if they're 10 years old, 11 years old, 15 years old, 17 years old.
This amendment is really dangerous, in my opinion. So I'm just strongly going to urge you to vote. No, even if you love the bill, this amendment really makes things more dangerous for our children. Thank you.
Does any other member wish to speak to the amendment? The chair recognizes representative Martinez.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. I'd just like to remind you guys of an incident in 1998, a young man by the name of Matthew Keechi. He was nine years old.
But he went into a restroom in Oceanside Harbor in California. He was a third grader while his aunt waited outside, and he was murdered.
I believe he's the one whose throat was slit when he was in there. Now, this was in a shelter, I believe, off the side of a highway.
But these things can happen. You never know who's going to be in the bathroom when you're not there.
My granddaughters, 13, 14, 15 years old, if it's an unfamiliar space, I go in the bathroom with them just to be safe. You can roll your eyes all you want.
If it doesn't affect you, roll your eyes, laugh, whatever you want to do. This is serious.
We need to think about the possibilities. A male going into a person who appears to be a male, going into a female bathroom is not a good thing.
And it also opens the door for a real male to go into the bathroom. Same thing with a female bathroom. I mean, a male bathroom.
There's nothing else can go in there, too. So we need to rethink what we're doing with some of this stuff in this bill.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Does any other member wish to speak to the amendment? The Chair recognizes Representative Humphries.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. I think this amendment makes a lot of sense, and I would encourage you to vote yes.
Does any other member wish to speak to the amendment? Seeing none, Representative Lewis, you may close on your motion.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. I close.
You've heard the motion by Representative Lewis to amend all those in favor, signified by saying aye.
I'll oppose, nay.
The ayes appear to have it.
The ayes do have it. The motion carries.
Representative Lewis, you stole the floor.
So we've been out this for a while, and I'm going to try and be as succinct as possible.
This bill really isn't that complicated.
This bill simply codifies societal norms.
That is what people expect.
That public spaces used for private purposes will be single sex, and that a person's identification documents will accurately reflect their biological sex.
That's just what people expect, and we're simply codifying that with this bill.
The bill has too many, two primary purposes. One is privacy and public safety.
With respect to bathrooms, but we're also talking, by the way, about more than bathrooms, we're talking about locker rooms, schools.
We're talking not just about adults, but we're talking about children in these public private spaces as well.
And I have heard from a number of constituents and others about concerns about both privacy,
especially women privacy and safety inside these public spaces where men are allowed to come in and use the facilities at the same time.
So both privacy and safety.
With respect to safety, there's another concern that hasn't been raised, but we did learn about this in our hearing on the bill.
That is in our in merge in situations where people come into say an emergency room, or they're in a car accident and they're incapacitated.
And what the hospitalist that from Wesley testified to was medical professionals need to know immediately whether that person is biological male or female in order to make good medical decisions.
And they will then in those circumstances rely heavily on what the driver's license says. So if the driver's license isn't accurate with respect to the biological sex of the person, it creates problems for the medical treatment.
And that will affect, by the way, not only the people who are the trans people, but anybody.
They need to have reliable information from the driver's license about the biological sex to provide them with the best medical treatment possible.
The other concern that really hasn't been addressed is law enforcement IDs.
What happens is when a police officer law enforcement officer stops somebody, they inevitably ask for the driver's license and what they then do is they go back into their squad car and whatever and they they send the information on the driver's license into the
CIS database and they on based on that driver's license and the information in it, which would include their birth date, their name, and their gender or their sex.
They made that that in I CIS database searches to determine whether, for instance, that individual has a warrant out for their arrest or has, you know, five felonies that they've been convicted of.
It would be nice. It would be important for that law enforcement to know with whom he or she is dealing.
So those are some of the concerns that I think.
Undergird, if you would, this bill.
And I think it's important that we keep those in mind.
I also want to respond to some of the arguments that my friends from the other side of the aisle have been making.
First of all, we've heard that the bill targets or discriminates is against transgenders. I reject that. Why?
Everyone in this bill is treated just the same.
It simply requires that everyone, whether they're a male who wants to be a female, female who wants to be a male, a male who wants to be a male, female who wants to be a male.
It doesn't matter. They use the private space in public, multiple occupancy spaces of their biological sex.
And it requires that they have identification documents that reflect the biological gender.
Having the gender marker on the driver's license, as I say, reflects the biological gender of the person and can actually be helpful to the transgender population.
We've also heard a lot about the cost of this. Look at our own building here.
There's not going to be a cost involved in this building coming into compliance with this bill.
We have genders designated multiple occupancy bathrooms, and we also have a family bathroom. There's not going to be any construction needed.
And I would doubt that there are very many government buildings in this state that don't have the same designations right and left or female and male.
The only difference is now there's going to be codification of that, and there's going to be enforcement of those sex distinctions, which are, as I said, really part, really part of just a societal norm.
Let's see.
There was some discussion of what's going to happen to people who don't know about the law when they come into Kansas. Well, I, I point out to you, you know, then marijuana laws were mentioned. We have marijuana distinctive different marijuana laws in neighboring states.
And that's the responsibility of those who come into Kansas or drive to Colorado or to Missouri to know what those laws are when they enter into those states.
The same way it'll be the responsibility of people to know that in this case. The other thing I would point out is the law actually does not hold them responsible in the first instance of violation.
It gives them a warning. That's it. Warning. Nothing else. Their second violation. They're subject to a thousand dollar penalty. And it's only upon the third that there's any kind of criminal sanction.
So I think this law does a good job of giving people notice of their obligations to comply with it.
And there's also been discussion about how unfortunate it will be for the concern expressed is that a person who is a, let's see, a person who is a woman, but, but looks like a man will enter a woman's private space.
Think about that. This bill will significantly reduce that problem because currently any man can enter any woman's bathroom without legal consequence.
That is a concern that we have. And I'm not saying that we're going to eliminate that problem, but we are going to significantly reduce the problem through this bill. So those who on this side of the aisle who are concerned about somebody looking like a man being in a woman's bathroom
should actually support this bill because it's significantly going to reduce the risk of that happening.
As far as the cost goes. Once again, the, I just don't think that there's going to be very many public buildings that are going to have to be reconfit bathrooms reconfigured or new new bathrooms built because of this bill.
So I don't think there's going to be great cost involved to these public entities. And they will have some time to take care of that under the bill. There's, if they're complained against, they have a cure.
If the entity that owns building is complained against, they have a cure period in which to fix the problem.
And that Mr. Chairman, I urge support of the bill. Thank you.
The chair recognizes representative Sutton for an announcement.
Thank you, Mr. Leader, Mr. Chairman.
I know this is going to break hearts, but in order for no one to feel any angst as the time ticks, I will be canceling insurance committee today.
I know, I know. We'll try to schedule a double one on another day. We'll try to get a Friday or something. But anyway, thank you. Thank you, Mr. Chair.
The chair recognizes representative Bryce for an announcement.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. Health and Human Services Committee will not be meeting today. We'll meet tomorrow at the regular time. Thank you.
Chair recognizes representative Tarwater for an announcement.
Attention, Commerce fans, bring your popcorn tonight. We're going to meet at about 1130 p.m. And so.
We are postponing today's meeting until tomorrow. We didn't have anything on the agenda tomorrow. And I was really looking forward to.
Figuring out what we could do together because I miss you guys when we're not around each other. So we're going to move today to tomorrow. That'll be all. Thank you.
Is there anybody else who wish the chair recognizes representative Lewis for an announcement?
A corrections committee will not be meeting today.
Representative, the chair recognizes representative Howerton for a announcement.
Thank you. Tell welfare. We will not meet today. We will continue that on Monday.
That's all I have.
Chair recognizes representative gets.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. We are moving today's LPA and inspector general for K-12 to tomorrow. It was pretty open day tomorrow. So we'll do that tomorrow. Thank you.
Chair recognizes representative sweetly for an announcement.
Higher education budget will not be meeting as well today. Thanks.
Is there anybody else wishing to speak to the bill? The chair recognizes representative Susan Ruiz.
This bill, as we all know, is not about keeping Kansans in their homes or expanding access to health care or helping families pay for childcare or funding for special education or lowering taxes or supporting small businesses.
This is why we were elected to do all of that and not what we're trying to do now.
And this bill seems to impose unfunded mandates.
I have a question for the carrier of the bill.
Yes, who is responsible for paying for the re issuance of licenses and birth certificates?
I'm not sure about that. That's a good question.
Yep, I'm fixing it. I'm going to fix it.
This is an unfunded mandate and.
They will be the reassurances of licenses and birth certificates.
And with that, I have an amendment.
The amendment here short the clerk will read.
I move to a mental health substitute for SB 244 on page five in line three after see by inserting no fee or other charge shall be assessed for the correction or re issuance of any birth certificate that is corrected pursuant to this section.
I represent you wish to speak to the bill.
Sorry, the amendment.
Yes, sir.
So there is no there's no stipulation in the bill as to who is responsible for the pain of the re issuance of the driver's license and a birth certificate.
So it does cost.
And this is an unfunded mandate.
The folks who are having to are going to be reissued a license or a birth certificate.
They're not asking for it.
They're not asking for this bill.
They shouldn't have to pay for it.
The state should have to be the one responsible for it.
I have a question for the carrier of the bill.
Is there is there anyone wishing to speak to the amendment.
Representative Humphries.
I understand the thought behind this.
And just so people know, I think it's $20 to get a new birth certificate.
And I think it's about 30 to get a new driver's license.
So I understand the thought, but I still think that we need to vote no on this amendment.
So that's what I would encourage you to do. Thank you.
Sorry, one else wishing to speak to the amendment. The chair recognizes representative Carlin.
Thank you, Mr. Chair, not to try to correct the previous speaker, but I did just apply.
I did get a birth certificate for my grandson, and it was $35.
And he lacked some papers that they needed that he had to send in.
And when he sent those papers in, that was $40.
So far, it's been about six months, and we still don't have the paperwork back.
He still doesn't have a birth certificate.
That's correct, because he had an error on his birth certificate.
So it is not easy to get a birth certificate when you, even when you're a representative and you're not a transgender person.
Thank you, Mr. Chair, Mr. Chair.
Does any other member wish to speak to the amendment? The chair recognizes representative Car.
Thank you, Mr. Speaker. I rise in support of this amendment.
I'm really disturbed by the fact that we would stand up in this body and just say, oh, well, it's just going to cost somebody something.
I mean, that's, we didn't do our due diligence from the start.
We don't have any idea what it costs in total.
And then just to throw our hands up in the air and shrug our shoulders and say, oh, well, they're just going to have to pay for it.
I think that's just a horrible thing to do. Thank you, Mr. Speaker.
Sir, anyone else wishing to speak to the amendment? The chair recognizes representative Mosley.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I rise in support of this amendment because the majority of Americans over 60% of them cannot afford an expense, an expected expense of $500 or more.
And this is a about 20% of that unexpected expense. People who fall into the LGBT community face chronic under employment.
And they're risking their constantly on the margins. You all are putting a mandate on them to spend money that they don't have to comply with the state bill that is very poorly thought out. And with that, I support this amendment. Thank you.
Is there anyone else wishing to speak to the amendment?
Seeing none. Representative, you may close.
I just really think that this is an unfunded mandate and the folks that are going to be affected by this bill are not asking for this.
So they should not carry the burden of the financial burden. Thank you, Mr. Chair.
I close.
You've heard the motion by representative Susan Ruiz to amend all those in favor signified by saying aye.
I'll oppose nay.
Here to have it, the division has been called. The clerk will open the roll and you may vote.
Seeing 15 hands, a roll call is in order.
Is every member had the opportunity to vote? The clerk will close the roll and take the tally. Does any member wish to change their vote?
Seeing none. 42 having voted in favor and 76 against the motion to amend the motion fails. Representative Susan Ruiz, you still have the floor.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Along with that unfunded mandate of the license and certificates.
There seems to be some confusion about whether bathrooms are going to have to be created.
The single use bathrooms.
Well, if new signage is going to have to go up.
So I'm going to once again ask the carrier the bill the question about the bathroom.
Once again, please clarify the bathrooms, the multi use bathrooms and a single use bathroom.
Okay, a multi occupancy private space means a facility designed or designated for simultaneous use by more than one individual in which an individual may be in a state of address in the presence of another individual.
Regardless of whether the facility provides curtains or partial walls for privacy. It includes but is not limited to restroom locker room changing room or shower room.
That's the multi single space is a facility designed or designated for use by only one individual at a time and in which the individual may be in a state of address.
Single occupancy private space includes but is not limited to a single toilet restroom with a locking door or a family restroom or changing room.
So follow up. So if if a governmental entity does not have single use restrooms, will they be required to create one a single use.
Absolutely not in this bill if they choose to of course they may, but they are not required to and that is very clear on page two line 17 through 22.
And if this governmental sorry one more if this governmental building office does not have that in a transgender person needs to use the facilities.
What are they supposed to do? Use the facilities that is on their driver's license.
And then you're good.
If that were to happen then there seems to be a violation then.
If the person appears because we really are basing a lot of things on appearance.
So if the person appears to be male.
And they are in a female bathroom.
Correct.
That's right. It's a violation.
I would think that most places are going to want to create a single use bathroom so that they can accommodate.
People that are coming in for services into their building, you know, they're not going to be.
Unkind and uncompassionate about that. They're going to want to.
To do that. They've not had to require they've not been required to do that before.
But now it's really is a requirement.
Doesn't appear to that be that way in the bill. It doesn't say you are required, but it really is going to end up being a requirement.
That I have another amendment.
The amendment appears short. The clerk shall read.
I move to amend house substitute for SB 244 on page 2 in line 16 after the period of inserting the governing body or chief administrative officer.
If no governing body exists, shall post a sign next to the door of any multiple occupancy private space dating.
This private space is for single sex use only as required by law enacted by the 2026 Kansas legislature.
Each governing body or chief administrative officer, if no governing body exists, shall provide personnel to monitor entry of each multiple occupancy private space.
At all times, such private space is open to the public. The costs associated with monitoring multiple occupancy private spaces shall be borne by the state.
Representative, do you wish to explain your amendment? Yes, Mr. Chair. Thank you.
So, the signage right now, of course, if you go to, you go to the restroom, there's either an L or there's an M or you have some kind of a figure, something, right, that, and you choose which one to go to.
We're being forced. This bill is forcing, I believe, a different signage and that the signage is that if you are transgender, you still have to use the restroom that is the, that's with the gender marker placed on your birth certificate.
Other people like that or not, they're going to be forced to do that. And there's going to be some folks that are going to be charged for that.
I think the, I think the signage needs to say that thanks to the 2026 legislature, the state legislature that you're required to do this now.
If you vote for this bill, then you need to own it. This is what this amendment says.
Is there a member wishing to speak to the amendment? Chair recognizes represent Humphreys.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. Let's just vote this one down. Thank you.
Is there any other member wishing to speak to the amendment? Seeing none, represent Susan Ruiz. You may close.
I close.
You've heard the motion by represent Susan Ruiz to amend. All those in favor signify by saying aye.
I'll oppose, nay.
The vision has been called. The clerk will open the roll and you may vote.
As every member had the opportunity to vote.
Thank you.
As every member had the opportunity to vote. The clerk will close the roll and take the tally.
35 having voted in favor and 85 against the motion fails. Representative Susan Ruiz, you still have the floor.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
There are multiple unintended consequences associated with this bill.
I've heard stories of in other states, I've not heard one in Kansas or has happened in Kansas, but that doesn't mean it hasn't happened.
When a woman has been assaulted by a man outside of the restroom as they were walking into the restroom.
They've been accused of looking like a man and we're asking them why are you going into a woman's restroom when the person is a woman.
It happens a lot because people are so hung up on appearances.
They don't look like a woman. They don't look like a man or they don't look manly enough. They don't look womanly enough.
That happens a lot. That form of discrimination happens a lot.
And I believe that's part of what's behind this bill.
That is going to be an unintended consequence. If a non-trans woman gets assaulted or gets falsely accused of going into a restroom, when somebody is saying that, well, you don't look like that.
You don't look like the woman. You don't look like a man.
I believe that there needs to be a fine for that for falsely accusing. I have an amendment.
The amendment appears short. The clerk will read.
I would like to amend how substitute for SB 244 on page four in line 24.
After two by inserting any individual who will accessing a multiple occupancy private space design for use only by such individual sex is aggrieved or is otherwise farmed by being falsely accused by allowing this section may bring a cause of action against the individual
making such false excusations. In bringing such action, the individual may seek either actual damages or liquidated damages in the amount of $1,000 as well as declatory and injunctive relief.
And by redesignating subsections paragraphs and clauses accordingly.
Representative, this amendment has not been turned into the clerk yet. Could you please submit to the clerk and then we'll continue the debate.
A reminder to the members. If you've received an amendment, please make sure you turn it into the clerk to save his time on the debate.
Thank you.
Represent your waste. Do you wish to explain your amendment?
Yes, I did prior to.
That the falsely aggrieved individual may seek actual damages or liquidated damages in the amount of $1,000.
Is there any member wishing to speak to the amendment. Representative Poskin.
Thank you, body. I rise in support of this amendment. In fact, representative, it was just two days ago that a freshman at the University of Kansas shared a story about her friend who had very short hair.
And she was in fact assaulted on the campus of the University of Kansas and two goons told her that she did not belong in the women's bathroom.
And maybe we need to start keeping track of that and I will put that person in contact with the representative. I stand in strong support of this amendment. Thank you.
Is there any other member wishing to speak to the amendment. Representative Lewis.
Yes, so thank you, Chairman, Chair. There are two things I would point out. First of all, defamation law should take care of this problem.
This is essentially trying to codify what's already in tort law. Representative, could you speak up just a little bit?
I'm sorry. Thank you. Our defamation law should take care of this problem. And it's essentially trying to somehow codify that. The second point is it says you can be sued if you make a false statement.
There's no requirement in the amendment that that false statement be made knowing it to be false or even negligently making making a false statement. So I think for those two reasons, I would vote against this.
Is there any is there any other member wishing to speak to the amendment. Seeing none represent for we should make close.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. My attempt was to match the language that's on page four, line 32. Any civil penalty collected by the attorney general pursuant to the section. Oh, sorry. That's not the one.
It is.
In the bill, there is a penalty of $1,000. That's what I was trying to match.
There it is.
Page four line between line 16 and 23.
It's an individual while accessing a multi occupancy private space designated for use only by such individual sex is agreed by the invasion of such individuals.
There's no privacy or is otherwise harmed by violation of the section and then it goes on to you can see actual damages, liquidated damages in the amount of 1000.
I just believe that if you're being falsely accused that this language would also apply and that the person would be able to sue for the $1,000.
Do you close on your motion.
You've heard the motion by representative Susan Ruiz to amend all those in favor signified by saying I.
All opposed nay.
May's appear to have it.
The vision has been called the clerk will open the role and you may vote.
As every member had the opportunity to vote the clerk will close the role and take the tally.
In 32 having voted in favor and 85 against the motion to amend the motion fails representative Susan Ruiz. You still have the floor.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
I have a question for the carrier the bill.
I think you'll note.
Okay.
Why, why, what is the reason for restricting the bathroom bill to government buildings.
That's a great question. I would say it's because private entities, we try to hold a little bit at a distance and we let businesses and profits and nonprofits operate on their own.
And so, I mean, if people would like to include private entities in this and they could, we could pass another bill later about that. But for this one, we're just doing government owned or lease buildings.
I just, I don't understand. I don't understand why we would, why we need this bill in the first place. And then.
And then the solely focus on government entities.
And what I really think is about is behind this is really only focusing on the capital.
You know, we get a lot of people comes into capital and what we've been told, always told that this is their house.
And we're telling them.
You're.
When you need to go and relieve yourself.
You have to double think, am I going through the right door is somebody going to ask me, am I going through the right door.
I think that.
Additionally, there's other things that should happen. I didn't bring amendments for it. I wanted to, but I didn't.
And that is that the visitor center.
Should have to be able to say that.
To tell people tell families that if you come to the capital.
Make sure you go to the to the restroom that is.
Associated with your birth certificate.
I mean, it's great that we don't we're not mandating people to walk around with their birth certificate to to have to verify that.
But I think people would feel that way.
This is not about this is does not help the state be welcoming. It does not help the capital to be welcoming.
At all, it goes way against that.
This bill goes against just basic human decency.
Human decency is treating each individual with kindness with respect and empathy.
It's about recognizing each individual, no matter what challenges they're facing.
Whether they're struggling physically, mentally, whether they're rich, whether they're poor.
What color they are.
Whether they're from a rural community or from an urban community doesn't matter.
This bill spits on basic human decency.
And I'm embarrassed that we've had to spend the entire day trying to defeat this thing.
There's something that I experienced back in 2018 when I was first elected.
And it's hurt me.
And I've kept it in my heart.
And I was warned.
There were two of us from Johnson County who were elected with the first two out legislators in Kansas.
We were warned.
Not so much to watch out, although some people said, Hey, I got your back.
If somebody messes with you, I got your back.
We were warned that maybe we would not have friendly other legislators that would be friendly towards me or towards my colleague.
And for the most part, I've been welcomed.
But there was one day when I was walking through the Capitol and there were a group of women legislators.
And overheard them say, I don't have a problem with the LGBT.
Oh, excuse me. I don't have a problem with the LGBT.
But I have a problem with the T.
And since 2019, these kinds of bills have been coming up against the transgender community.
It feels to me that this bill is targeted to a specific person, specific legislator in our community.
And it's wrong.
I think it's very discriminatory.
It's very hurtful.
And it feels like a retaliatory act.
I urge you to vote no on SB 244. Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Does any other member wish to speak to the bill? The chair recognizes representative Featherston.
Sorry, I represent just a moment.
The chair recognizes represent Adam Smith for an announcement first. I apologize.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. Just a quick announcement. House taxation has been postponed until next week. So there's no house tax this afternoon.
Now the chair recognizes represent Featherston. I apologize.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
So in 1961, the people of Kansas had a constitutional amendment in which they voted for local control.
We make a big deal about that in this chamber and in this building. Local control respect our local entities.
This bill violates that respect we have for our local entities, just like the entire process of this bill coming to this floor today violated the trust that our constituents have put in us.
My community, especially the business community, prides itself on being a welcoming community and they hear directly from our business community.
People want to move to my town because we welcome everybody.
This bill inhibits my city's ability to grow and for us to live in peace.
I did have the opportunity to step out during this hearing today to talk to my city to see what they did feel concerned about.
These are the things that my city is concerned about and I think probably also yours.
I don't find any of them addressed in this bill.
It's causing affordable health care, affordable child care, property tax reduction, especially for our seniors.
Fully funding special education, fully funding our schools, having a livable minimum wage.
Most of all, my city is concerned.
Are we doing anything up here to make life better for any Kansas at all?
As I think so far, I write a newsletter every week.
And every week, I'm like, I got nothing good to tell you.
Nothing has come across this floor that helped anybody, although I will say the AG bills that crossed the floor today that went through another committee.
I do think those helped somebody. So thanks for that.
But I'm tired of writing to my constituents and say, I'm wasting your tax dollars being up here, except I'm not because I'm standing on the right side of history.
So this bill is supposed to be about privacy.
Well, in my town, and I would suspect many of yours, we actually call non gendered bathrooms privacy bathrooms.
So we got it covered. If you can't cover that in your city, okay, you do you, but we got it covered.
We know their privacy bathrooms. We like that door all the way to the floor.
We like to be efficient. We like to bring our kids in, grandkids, you know, we don't want to be kidnapped or human trafficked because we couldn't bring them into the bathroom with us.
But I guess that's another point.
This bill is also supposed to be about protecting women.
Something that really would protect women that this body did pass is expansion of mammogram coverage.
Remember, we had a long discussion about it. We passed it.
And leadership on one end just had to kill that over and over and over.
We'll get to talk about it again, though, this year, don't you worry.
Finally, I think there are a lot of days we pass things like don't make a big deal in people's lives.
They make a big deal in somebody's lives, but they're, you know, it's kind of down the middle. That's great. No big deal.
But there are days like today where I have to really question the state of my soul for being around this kind of ugly talk and hatefulness.
This bill does real harm to Kansas families.
I have never had to text a constituent over a bill to say, please prepare yourself for the worst, except for earlier unconstitutional, by the way, versions of this bill.
And it does not make me proud to have to text my constituents and tell them I have nothing to say.
I don't know how to tell you to protect your child.
And I didn't come up here to hurt families. I sure as heck didn't come up here to hurt kids who have no voice.
I'm not here to harass people who make up such a small percentage of our population that you could barely pick a handful out of a crowd.
So I would urge you to vote no on this and to stop harming Kansas families, stop wasting taxpayer dollars, and let's do something that actually helps our people.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Does any other member wish to speak to the bill? The Chair recognizes Representative Meyer.
Hi, everyone.
That you were waiting on me to come up here, huh? It's been a minute.
So to start, I would like to clarify some language that some of the members of the body have been using.
I want to remind you that transgender men are men. Transgender women are women.
So when they're walking into that restroom, oh, I love how you're smiling. Great. Wonderful.
When they're walking into that restroom, as one of my colleagues stated, with a full beard, fully looking like a dude,
or when they're in there with their big breasts and cleavage everywhere in the women's restroom,
you're going to say, hey, pull down your pants. Let me see what you got in there. Is that what we're going to do?
I don't believe that you are a man or a woman. I mean, who's going to do that?
Just wanted to remind you.
And I mean, I'll come back to that point.
But to get serious again, I want to remind you also that people of the transgender community are four times more likely to be a victim of a violent assault.
That's fat. Oh, are we laughing at that too? That's cool.
To a previous representatives point about her sexual assault, and you are so brave for sharing that with us. Thank you.
Many of us have experienced that. Many of us have experienced sexual assault or sexual harassment.
We don't talk about it. We don't report it because we know who's really going to hurt.
And it's going to be the survivor, right? The survivor loses everything.
Did you know that over 99% of the perpetrators of sexual assault are cisgender men?
Google it.
I think I said this a couple years ago when we were having a conversation about another one of these asinine bills.
That you need to be calling out the men around you for their behavior.
For the fact that they raped women.
For the fact that they sexually assault children.
For the fact that they do any of these number of things that you all are inventing happen on a regular basis with transgender individuals.
Because the facts don't support that either.
And I think you've heard all of this thing that today. I know we're tired of the debate.
But you guys are bringing the bills. We're just trying to protect people.
And back to that.
The issue you are trying to solve is with rape culture with toxic masculinity.
With red-pilled young men and older men.
With the patriarchal power structure that enables men to continue to get away with sexual assault.
That's what we should be addressing. Not making up an issue because somebody is uncomfortable.
Because somebody is triggered.
I've been here. What is this? Five years now? Every single year.
We've had something like this come up.
For what?
Because people have a personal vendetta against a group. Because you're discriminating.
This whole hearing process was ridiculous. What hearing? Right?
We don't allow people to come in and share their thoughts and speak their mind. We don't take this seriously.
And then I'd like to address some other things that a member said earlier about transgender children.
And cisgender children in the school setting. And how uncomfortable they are.
So as you all know from my years of talking about this.
I have a child who's gendered on conforming. Right?
They are more uncomfortable than the cisgender children that she was talking about.
I don't even believe that that's something that they feel. I mean, I understand that community doesn't really have a lot of out transgendered children, but mine does.
And in my community, those trans kids are worried and they're scared for their safety. I get calls from these kids.
I get letters. I get emails constantly from these kids and their family members saying we are afraid for our future.
We don't feel comfortable in settings that discriminated against us, that force us to use bathrooms that don't align with our gender identity.
They know. And then why are we doing this to adults? I mean, this is ridiculous.
I really truly debate. I'm sorry.
I just don't think that the claims that the previous representative made about cisgender children feeling uncomfortable are truly that valid.
And I'd like to see some more information on that, frankly.
This is a hard day, everyone. I know we're tired.
But I want you to think about something else, too.
When we're talking about survivors of sexual assault, what would happen if an individual,
you know, we don't know if they really need to find out if they're using the right bathroom for their gender identity or not.
But it seems to me that folks might take this opportunity to further traumatize someone who had been a victim of sexual abuse or sexual assault or sexual harassment through saying,
you're saying, hey, I don't believe you're really a woman or a man, pull down your pants and let me see what you got.
No, but that's what's going to happen.
You can't tell me that you're going to look again, a man with a full beard, walking into a women's restroom and say, yeah, okay, I mean, I think we're trying to do the opposite, right?
You don't want men with beards in women's spaces, right? But now you're doing it.
They could have a penis, too. They may have had surgery.
But according to this bill, it doesn't matter. So you still got penises in there.
Still got vaginas in the men's room. I mean, hey, think about it.
Just doesn't make sense.
I just, and that's the part I can't get over. How is this going to be enforced? Who's going to check?
Who's going to stand out that bathroom door and tell me, pull down your pants? Let me see.
You know? Literally.
I don't know. I'm tired of this conversation.
But if we want to talk about women's rights, why don't we talk about that, too, since that was a big point someone brought up.
It doesn't protect women and girls. It weaponizes women's rights and uses this to invalidate people at the core of their humanity.
And it creates so many legal problems in the long term.
You can't even run away from that. So, you know, we're talking about we don't have a fiscal note on this.
Well, we should probably include how much this is going to cost some legal fees, too, because this is, it's a lawsuit waiting to happen.
I mean, we're waiting on it. Bring it.
This bill is based on lies and misinformation, and it feeds into stereotypes, and you all know how I feel about it.
I've made my point, but I want you to continue to consider the impact that this has on the people that you were saying that you were trying to protect.
This will impact sexual assault survivors. This will impact children. This will impact women. This will impact men at a level that I don't think anyone is really considering.
And as I said, who's going to ask us to take down our pants? How is this going to be enforced? How is this not sexual assault and battery to ask to do so anyway?
I mean, we're talking about survivors. We're back to that.
I'll just end it with this.
I am really, really exhausted by this conversation, and I know that our community members, especially those who are the most marginalized and disenfranchised, are even more exhausted.
I came out here to fight for our communities, and that's what I'm doing, and that's why I'm up here every single time.
One of these bills comes up. I know you're tired of me talking about it, but I don't bring these bills.
I want to do things for Kansans, and that's not this.
But our communities are afraid, and they're tired of watchness, make a mockery of the system.
They're not having true bill hearings. You know, committee hearings where people can actually come and share their thoughts.
And even when they do not being hurt or taken seriously.
So, you know, I'll be done here, but I want you all to consider this for the future.
This is not how we should be operating as a government. Nobody is really thinking this through.
And I'm just done, but no.
The chair recognizes representative Bieler for an announcement.
Ten to Commerce fans.
Just kidding.
House Social Services Budget Committee. We are canceling today's meeting.
So, 330 House Social Services Budget Committee is canceled.
We will pick up tomorrow with our scheduled agenda and adjust as we need to.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Is there any other member wishing to speak to the bill?
The chair recognizes representative Weiko.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
Will the carrier of the bill please stand for a question?
I'm going to shift us back to the driver's license portion of this bill.
All right.
It's my understanding and I looked at the attorney general's testimony that he submitted at the hearing that one of the reasons for the initial legislation was because.
Accuracy on driver's license was really important.
Is that true?
Particularly for people to be able to like identify somebody or see somebody.
The initial, meaning the women's bill of rights?
No, I'm sorry.
The bill you heard the second day of session this year.
Yes.
It was for accuracy.
All right.
Okay. Thank you.
Body.
I stand in very, very strong opposition to this bill.
However, if the supporters of this bill are truly concerned about the information on driver's licenses, then I think it's important we are consistent and we look at other descriptors on our driver's licenses.
As I was thinking about this, I pulled out my driver's license, which frankly I hadn't looked at in a really long time.
And I thought, I looked at what it said, I said, says my hair color is the same.
I'm getting a little gray, maybe from this job, but generally it's the same.
My eye color is the same.
My height's the same.
But guys, my weight is not the same.
It's really inaccurate.
I think the weight listed on my driver's license is so different from my actual weight that it actually might be hard for someone to use the information on my driver's license in order to identify me.
In the attorney general's testimony in support of this legislation, it says this bill restores quote, uniformity and accuracy to state issued documents.
I have an amendment.
The amendment appears long. Is there objection to the reading of the amendment?
There is objection the clerk will read.
I move to amend house substitute for SB244 on page five following line four by inserting new section three.
Any person applying for the issuance or renewal of a driver's license or a non drivers identification card shall be weighted at the location where such person is making such application or in lieu of being weighed in person.
This person may submit documentation signed by a physician stating such person's weight provided such documentation was issued by such physician not more than six weeks prior to the date that such person submitting the application.
The weight recorded or submitted with documentation pursuant to subsection A shall be the weight indicated on such person's driver's license or non drivers identification card and in all other information pertaining to such person that is reported by the division of vehicles.
Section four, it shall be unlawful to have a difference in weight of more than 15 pounds from the weight stated on such person's driver's license or non drivers identification card.
If a person's weight is different from the weight stated on such person's driver's license or non drivers identification.
The objection to waving the reading has been lifted or withdrawn.
Representative Michael, you may explain your amendment.
Thank you, Mr Chairman.
In the name of accuracy, this is what this amendment does.
In order to ensure people have accurate weight listed on their driver's license, they will have to either use a scale at the DMV to provide an accurate weight.
Or provide documentation from a physician that is no more than six weeks old that states their weight.
Furthermore, I know there's been a lot of debate today about whether there's a fiscal note to this bill that we haven't seen.
But in the case there is, it creates a fee fund to pay for renovations that will be needed to bathrooms and government buildings, and it funds that fee fund by the following ways.
When someone renews their license, a fee will be assessed if a person's actual weight is more than 15 pounds different from the weight listed on their expiring license.
Additionally, if someone has a weight fluctuation of more than 15 pounds, they will have to renew their license and the fee collected for these renewals will be allocated to the fee fund.
And I'll note that there's an exception for someone who is pregnant or up to 12 months postpartum.
I remember wish to speak to the amendment. The chair recognizes representative Meyer.
Yeah, it may come as no surprise. I'm not really sure how I feel about this amendment y'all.
I mean, you know, if it mentioned hair color too, we might have some real issues because my hair color is obviously different every week, right?
What about piercings? I came back with like two new piercings on my face.
Hey, my driver's license says I weigh 150. I don't really want that to change.
I'm working my way down there, but we know it's not accurate.
That's been on there. I think since I was about 19 years old. I mean, you don't even have to update it. What I want to step on a scale though in front of everybody.
I'm not sure.
I am.
God, I'm having a hard time with this one. I don't know which way to tell you to vote, but vote your heart, whatever you want on your driver's license to say.
Is there any other member wishing to speak to the amendment? The chair recognizes representative Mosley.
Thank you, Mr. Chair and thanks to my colleague. I am also about 10 pounds heavier than my weight, but it's also thanks to this job.
One of the comforts during the debate for the license portion of this, of this bill spoke about how medical professionals are not able to make quick decisions if they don't know your gender.
But I think that when it comes to things like anesthesiology or facts, paste decisions, it is actually more advantageous for a medical professional to know how much you actually weigh.
So I am in full support because medical professionals really talked about how hard it was for them to actually be able to get provide proper medical assistance.
So I support this amendment. Thank you.
Does any other member wish to speak to this amendment? The chair recognizes representative car.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. With the carrier of the bill, please stand for a question.
The amendment, I'm sorry.
Happy to.
So my question is, and maybe you said it, but I didn't get it.
My weight has probably changed slightly also so.
Tell me who pays for it.
If I have to have my driver's license changed.
You would pay for that.
Thank you.
Is there any other member wishing to speak to the amendment, the chair recognizes representative or a paisa.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. I too am very conflicted about this amendment.
I do appreciate my colleague from Lawrence do speaking about the health care professionals that weight does matter.
But also what was brought up during that committee testimony was gender.
When you are in a car crash, when there is something extreme happening in your life, regardless of who you are, they treat the person.
It's a for airway.
Free for breathing.
See for circulation.
Please let's remember the ABCs and not be focused on what is actually on our driver's license because number one, we are people first.
And that's who health care providers treat our people.
Not designations are marking on their driver's license.
And if you have a health care provider that's looking at your driver's license first before they're treating you.
Please find another health care provider because you want appropriate treatment and you want to have your life saved and not to be worried about other things. Thank you.
Sir, the other member wishing to speak to the amendment. The chair recognizes Representative Schlien Seepen.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. And thank you to the bringer of the amendment. I find this an exciting amendment.
Over the summer, I lost 38 pounds.
I'm still down 25. I just pulled my driver's license to see how much I weigh.
And I weigh 180 pounds, which means I've got another 10 pounds to go.
And with that new gym over in the docking building, folks, that's something to strive for. I'm in all in favor of this one. Thank you.
Is there any other member wishing to speak to the amendment? The chair recognizes Representative Humphreys.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I really think this is a frivolous amendment.
I think that, of course, your weight changes. Of course, your hair color can change.
But it's really making the point of the importance of this bill because your sex cannot change and your birthday doesn't change.
And those are the things that we need to identify people. And that's what's important. So please vote this down.
Is there any other member that wishes to speak to the amendment? Seeing none, Representative Weichel, you may close.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
Body surprisingly, I'm in full agreement with the carrier of this bill. This is frivolous.
I fully acknowledge this amendment is ridiculous. It's absurd.
I would also argue is personally invasive and harmful to people.
Just like the underlying bill.
I was raised to treat others as I would like to be treated.
And I offer this amendment today to make a point about dignity, treating people with dignity, and how this body chooses to use the immense power that we have.
I didn't run for office to spend my time in power stripping people of their dignity.
It's infuriating to me and my constituents that this body is using our time to further marginalize vulnerable populations and have us debating people's personal information on their driver's license and which bathrooms they can and cannot use.
Imagine, imagine, just for a minute, the good we could do for Kansans if we focused our energy on actual problems that our constituents care about.
We have so much power to do good things.
We can make sure people have access to health care.
We can make sure every Kansas child has a world-class education and that young adults who want to be electricians or teachers or welders or doctors or whatever can afford to seek those opportunities.
We can make sure our democracy is robust, that rural communities thrive, and that we preserve our water and natural resources for future generations of Kansans.
We have that power. We can make Kansas the best place to live and raise a family.
We can do so much if only we would spend our time doing that.
Mr. Chairman, I withdraw my amendment.
Is there any objection to withdrawing the amendment?
Seeing none, the amendment is withdrawn. We're back on the bill.
The Chair recognizes Representative Wausinger for an announcement.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
General government budget will not meet today. We will add everything for tomorrow. Thank you.
Is there any other member wishing to speak to the bill? The Chair recognizes Representative Mosley.
Thank you, Mr. Chair, and I find it very surprising that folks who have been telling us that gun-free signs on schools don't stop who want to do harm or telling us that a sign on the bathroom will stop someone who wants to do harm.
But that is not why I'm up here.
On November 18, 2025, a transgender woman known as Girl La La online was shot by her intimate partner.
Girl La La joined one of the most vulnerable groups, Trans Women of Color.
Trans women and gender non-converming individuals are more likely to be victims of violence than to perpetrate it.
Once again, I would remind you that you're more likely to be harmed by your member of clergy, someone in religious authority than you are a trans person.
And with that, I have an amendment.
The amendment appears long. Is there an objection to waiving the reading of the amendment?
Yes.
Okay, there is an objection, so the clerk will read.
I move to amend House Subsitude for SB244 on page 5, following line 4 by inserting, new section 3, as provided in this section, each state agency, not later than October 1st, 2026.
And each year thereafter, shall file with the Division of the Budget, such agency's budget estimates for the next fiscal year of a listing of all programs of the agency that provide services for the public.
For victims of domestic violence, the amount of the agency's request for appropriations to fund services for victims of domestic violence, and the amount which will be spent on such services in the next ensuing fiscal year.
Beginning of fiscal year 2028, and each fiscal year thereafter, each agency shall certify to the Secretary of Administration that the agency has expended annual funding for services, including shelters for multi-gender victims of domestic violence.
The Secretary shall compile all such certifications and informations and submit a report to the House of Representatives Committee on Appropriations and the Senate Committee on Ways and Means annually on the first day of the regular session of the legislature beginning in 2028.
As used in this section, one, domestic violence means the name as defined in KSA 21-5111, and amendments thereto, and two, gender means the same as defined in KSA 77-207, and the amendments thereto, and by renumbering sections accordingly.
On page 1 in the title in line 13, after the semicolon, by inserting, requiring state agencies to expand annual funding for services, including shelters for multi-gender victims of domestic violence.
Representative, would you like to explain your amendment?
Yes, so this amendment, essentially, what it does is that many domestic violence shelters receive funds from the state general fund, and I want to ensure that, and this bill has the potential to be interpreted where there needs to be single, single-gender shelters.
And so I want to make sure that we have funds set aside for multi-gender victims of domestic violence, because, like I said, the transgender community, they expand in gender non-conforming individuals, experience domestic violence at much higher rates, and they tend to be the victims, especially transgender individuals of color.
I am very blessed to represent House District 46, and then my colleague to the south of me is very blessed to represent House District 10, I believe, but that House District has Haskell University, and because it has Haskell University, we have a lot of individuals who are indigenous in both of our communities.
The false binary that is gender the way that we are discussing it today actually leaves out two-spirited individuals who are within the indigenous community who are to gender, and they have more than one gender, they do not see themselves within the binary, they see themselves as human, and they see themselves as something in between.
I also represent the University of Kansas, where we have a lot of individuals who are gender non-conforming and also transgender, and those individuals, if they experience domestic violence, deserve to have a safe place to go.
I sit on a domestic violence board, I sit on the domestic violence board for my community, and I want to ensure that we are able to still serve individuals who have the potential to be victims of violence as we are claiming that we care about victims of violence.
And for that, I'll stand for questions.
Is there any member wishing to speak to the bill? The chair recognizes Representative Humphreys.
I'm sorry, wishes to speak to the amendment.
Does any other member wish to speak to the amendment?
Body police stand at ease for just a moment.
The chair recognizes Representative Humphreys.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. It's a little confusing. We had to figure out definitely what it was.
I think there's a question if it's germane. I'm not going to question that officially, but I would just ask the body to vote down the amendment. Thank you.
Is there any other member wishing to speak to the amendment? Seeing none, Representative, you may close on your motion to amend.
I'm going to try not to mess this up.
So with that being said, I once we have our claiming in this body that we care about victims and we want to protect individuals and we want to protect women, especially.
And this gives us the opportunity to put our money where our mouths are.
And so I move that you guys, I forgot what he was supposed to say.
I move my amendment. Thank you.
You've heard the motion from represent mostly to amend all those in favor signify by saying aye.
I'll oppose nay.
Nays appear to have it, but division has been called the clerk will open the roll and you may vote.
Seeing 15 hands roll call is in order.
Every member had the opportunity to vote.
Clerk will close the roll and take the tally.
Is there any member wishing to change their vote?
Seeing none, 38 having voted in favor and 77 against the motion fails and we're back on the bill represent mostly you still have the floor.
When I run for office, I run for office as a Democrat.
When I step in this building, I run at I'm a Kansas and I want to do the most amount of good for the most amount of Kansas.
I find it very sad that we've been here for the last like what six hours four hours it feels like six and we're having to basically fight a bill that is stripping.
Our Kansas our brothers and sisters are siblings of their basic dignity.
People just want to be able to live and I've never seen people who are fully secure with themselves who want to control other people. Thank you.
Does any other member wish speak to the bill? The chair recognizes representative Sawyer Clayton.
Thank you, Mr. Chair body. I would like to thank you for your patience and I would like to start off by talking about how proud I am of my pro LGBT voting record.
It has been a strong voting record regardless of which side of the aisle that I've been on.
But I also want to bring up the fact that it is not lost on me that there are Kansas, some of whom who have reached out to me directly that have expressed genuine fear or concern about being in the restroom with someone that may or may not at least according to whatever they think fall under the same gender identity as they are.
I would be remiss if I'm not looking at and recognizing their genuine concerns as well.
And I believe that as a legislator, I can support both my friends and colleagues who are transgender and my constituents as well as doing the best that I can to assuage the concerns that are real and genuine.
Now, and unfortunately appear to be riled up by some members of the legislature.
But I'd like to talk a little bit about some of the goals that the vice chair of judiciary mentioned earlier in his speech.
He talked about how two points to him were very important.
Those points are privacy and safety.
And honestly, when he speaks, I could not agree more.
I think that a lot of the people who have reached out to me who have been afraid of either they themselves or maybe their daughters being in the restroom with someone who might not appear to be the same gender that they are is they are genuinely afraid of them being
assaulted or their children being assaulted.
I do not, however, think that those people are afraid of trans folks assaulting them.
What I hear from these constituents of mine is a concern about a group of people exploiting a potential loophole by dressing up as women to go in and assault people when they are in a state of vulnerability.
And that group of people that they are actually afraid of are, and I intend no offense to the majority of this body, it's men.
It's men that we are afraid of.
I have spent my entire life from when I was old enough to walk and talk being afraid of being hurt by men.
When I found out that I was pregnant, that I was having a daughter, I was joyful and she's amazing.
And I love being a parent, but I was terrified of what could happen to my daughter at the hands of men.
When I found out I was having a son, I was even more scared as someone who grew up with all sisters.
I didn't know what I would do as a parent of a little boy.
I wasn't afraid of bringing my son into the women's room without me.
Where was I afraid of sending him?
The men's room without me, his mother, to protect him.
That is where the concerns of Mike's constituents are.
They are not anti-trans.
They are anti-men exploiting a loophole and using that to assault women and children.
What's been interesting to me is that I've talked about this quite a bit.
I am a history major and I love going down rabbit holes in particular when it comes to our duties as legislators.
One of our most important duties as was stated by the Vice Chair of Judiciary is to make sure that our constituents are safe and that they have privacy.
We're going to have to go back in time to look a little bit about the infrastructure of something that is a little bit icky to talk about, but every single one of us in this room do it.
That is using the restroom or toileting as would be the proper terminology here.
If you look at the history of public restrooms, public restrooms for men actually existed even as early as Mesopotamian times.
You have seen a lot of archaeological artifacts where you have these public restrooms where it is several toilets together, no wall together, nothing like that, where you have a lot of men using the toilet together.
Love that for you guys.
It's not exactly the type of lack of privacy that I would prefer, but you see a lot of that.
A lot of locker rooms or changing rooms or bathing facilities are also all for men.
That goes back especially to Greco-Roman times.
We won't speak about some of the consensual things that Greco-Roman folks engaged in and why anyone who would support such a lack of privacy might be in favor of that, but it can be heavily implied.
You don't start seeing public restrooms for women until the late Victorian era.
And I want you all, if you so desire, if you're interested in this urinary history lesson, is to go Google something called the urinary leash and separate spheres.
Anyone who has taken a gender studies course knows that in the Victorian era and in eras before that women were primarily kept at home, not necessarily because people gave one gosh darn about our privacy or safety, but because we were property.
And people did not want their property to be damaged, in other words, raped or assaulted.
In late Victorian times, especially as the industrial revolution started coming up, you start seeing more public restrooms for women.
And that is when you start seeing that extension of or that getting away from the separate spheres.
The urinary leash actually existed because before there were public restrooms for women, there was only one place that we could go and that was at home.
There were no public restrooms for us to go in.
So you start seeing these public restrooms separated by gender for both men and women coming up.
And for the most part, some of the arguments that I have heard my colleagues talking about today have been talking about very real fears that women and girls have of being assaulted in restrooms.
And there seems to be a misconception stated where people say that just because you are in a single gender space that you are automatically safe.
And I would argue that to the contrary.
So, like many boomer and Gen X women, and I have talked with some of my female colleagues about this, I grew up in Johnson County and I attended public schools.
And one of the things that I had to do because my teacher made me and made my other classmates do this in order to get a grade was that in my all female locker room.
So you really didn't have, at least at my time, was not aware of any transgender or gender nonconforming students who would have been in the restroom with me in the late 80s or in the locker room with me in the late 80s.
But by God, if you think that I was safe in that locker room, think again.
My gym teacher forced us to undress in our locker rows and then walk completely nude to a shower that we had to take our grade was based on this.
And then we had to go back to our lockers with a towel about the size of a Kleenex.
It was horrific.
I am still not okay.
I mean, there are a lot of reasons why I'm not just to bring some levity, but that is one of them.
And, but honestly, that is a huge problem.
And you know what?
All female space supposed to be super safe.
And yet you have an adult female authority figure telling minor children that they have to undress and not just undress partially and change out for gym, but get all the way down to the nude and be in front of their minor classmates and in front of an adult.
That is wrong.
And in fact, a lot of school districts, thank God, are starting to phase this out.
You're also starting to see issues with this in private schools as well.
You can look up case law.
There is a Catholic school that had issues with this.
I want to say in Indiana that are starting to phase this out because you know what?
Just being one gender together in a locker room does not make you safe.
We also want to look at the way that we use the toilet differently.
By necessity, it is going to take us ladies a little bit longer of an amount of time to use the restroom.
We menstruate.
We have to take our pants down.
We have to sit down.
It takes us a little bit of time to undress and to do our business in a sanitary and appropriate way.
The public restrooms for men did not always have urinals, but the urinal was first patented in 1866, I believe, here in the United States.
Although it was also widely used in France.
Again, this is a thing that you know now.
You're welcome.
But the problem with urinals is this.
We had an amendment a couple of hours ago, it seems, a couple of years ago.
We've been here for a while and we'll be here for a while longer.
And that's appropriate because we need to have this discussion properly.
But a couple of hours ago, there was an amendment that was brought that dropped the age of boys going to the restrooms with their moms from 12 to nine.
So I have an issue with this as a mother and I'll tell you why.
Not all men's rooms, at least from what I understand, from what you fellas have told me and from pictures I've seen on the Internet is because I'm not going in there.
I don't know if y'all wash your hands.
But not all men's rooms have private areas where a little boy of 10 or 12 can urinate in peace.
Instead, we have urinals, in some cases, trough urinals where there isn't even a divider between individuals where you have minor boys standing with their genitals completely exposed.
Right next to you within inches of the exposed genitals of grown adult men.
Yeah, and as a mother that horrifies and disgusts me, it's not appropriate.
It is dangerous.
And you know what?
It doesn't fit with what our vice chair said this bill should have, which is safe and private.
There's another issue that I have, as should surprise none of you.
But when we talk about locker rooms, not only my awful experience, and it's the one beef I have with the Shawnee Mission District, I don't know what they were thinking.
But when we normalize children and adults, even of the same gender being nude and showering and changing together, they didn't want to remember a story that came out around in 2012 about Penn State.
Regarding Sandusky, because I do, as a mother, I most definitely do, that man raped boys in the shower at a public building.
And guess what?
Mary, a trans person was present.
But yet, little boys got raped, and you want to know why?
Because we keep pushing this idea that forced public nudity is somehow the norm.
Men and little boys showering together is somehow healthy.
It is not.
That is how assault happens.
That is not safe, and that is not private.
I think that a lot of you folks on this side of the aisle have been pretty good sports today, because I think a lot of you have been told that you are awful, that you're monsters.
And I agree, I believe that actually some of you really genuinely do have good intent.
I mean, some of you, I'm never going to think you have good intent, but there are a lot of people that I legit think are genuinely good folks.
And that you really do, from the depths of your soul, want to protect children, and want to protect women, and frankly, want to protect men.
But as I have very clearly stated here, unless changes are made to this bill, the culture of our current bathrooms and shower rooms that has nudity everywhere and normalizes it, especially with adults and minors together, does nothing for the privacy of our children.
For the privacy or safety of people.
I have an amendment that will fix that.
The amendment appears long.
Is there any objection to waving the reading of the amendment?
Yes.
Clerk will read.
I move to amend house substitute for SB 244 on page two in line one after six by inserting nudity.
Means any state of undress in which the human genitals, pubic region, buttocks, or female breast at a point below the top of the area.
As less than completely and opaquely covered seven on page three in line 36 after insert after section by inserting a also on page three in line 38 after see by inserting or be for an individual be present in a multiple occupancy private space.
In a state of nudity unless such individual is.
I in a dollar shower designed for single occupancy use and it's not visible to any other individuals who may be in the multiple occupancy private space to under three years of age or three and disabled and being provided assistance by another individual.
Also on page three also in line 38 after the period by inserting to on page four in line four.
I'm sorry on page four in line nine by striking one and inserting to in line 19 after sex by inserting or by an individual appearing in a state of nudity in line 20 by striking.
Of the opposite sex and by redesignating subsections paragraphs of paragraphs and clauses accordingly.
Representative, would you like to explain your amendment?
Absolutely. Thank you, Mr. Chair and thank you for your patience.
So what this amendment does is as you heard, it makes it illegal with the same crime or cause of action as is for impersonating other another gender or whatever it is you folks like to call it.
But it sets that same level of crime when it comes to bathroom nudity.
So, for instance, if I am going into the ladies room, I'm shutting my little stall behind me and no one is seeing any of my business.
But that is not the case in the men's room. You've got grown men waving around God knows what in front of children and this amendment makes that a crime because it should be.
When it comes to showers, that also makes it a crime.
So you don't have those creepy gym teachers forcing children to undress and you don't see any more Sandusky scenarios in Kansas because we don't do that here.
We're better than that.
It does allow for an exception.
So, for instance, not all changing tables are within the confines of a handicapped stall, right?
Sometimes changing tables are out where everyone can see them, so I wanted to make it okay for parents who are diapering a baby or a small toddler to be able to take care of that child's toileting needs without violating that nudity clause.
You also see that I have included a clause for disabled folks because not all disabled folks can toilet on their own without assistance.
And so I wanted to make sure that those folks also were protected.
So that is what the amendment does. It finishes the work that this bill starts by actually truly providing privacy and safety instead of lip service. I'd love to see you all oppose it.
I dare you.
Is there any member wishing to speak to the amendment.
Representative Humphreys.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
I would suggest to all of you that you vote no on this amendment. Thank you.
Is there any further discussion on the amendment seeing none representative, you may close.
Wow, I never thought that a colleague of mine would want to see children naked and have kids and adults naked together, but boy, this day keeps getting weirder and weirder.
So, if you think that.
Representative, you'll refrain from impugning the motives of fellow members and there'll be decorum in the chamber.
You may continue.
Sorry, it's hard to talk without impugning someone's motives because if you vote no, you support adults and children being naked together.
If you vote no.
I have said what the amendment does.
Representative continue.
I will close on my amendment that preserves privacy and safety for adults and children in Kansas. We know what a yes or a no vote does. I would like to ask for a division and a roll call vote. Thank you.
You've heard the motion by representative Sawyer Clayton to amend all those in favor. Oh, I'm sorry. We've called division.
The clerk will open the role and you may vote.
Not seeing 15 hands seeing 15 hands a roll call is an order.
Thank you.
Is every is every member had the opportunity to vote?
The clerk will close a roll and take the tally. Does any member wish to change their vote?
Seeing none with 34 voting in favor and 82 against the motion to amend fails. Representative, you still have the floor.
Good. Well, my goodness. I apologize. So I would like to speak a little bit more about toilets and toileting and efficiency and control.
So how many of you all have been somewhere where the line to the ladies room is out the door.
And the line to the men's room is this short. So.
I can't say any more jokes about people not washing their hands because that would be perceived as imputing. But, um, but let's just say that it does take us a little bit longer to get our business done than it does to get men business done in the restroom.
And one thing that we really need to look at is that this does cover publicly owned buildings.
We will be debating a very important publicly owned building that is very important to the economic development of the state and that would be the new chief stadium.
So if you do your research, you will see that there are a number of stadiums now that are being built with these multi individual usage gender inclusive bathrooms.
If you have ever been to MCI, there is one of these at the airport and this bill would make that illegal to construct.
And the way that that bathroom at MCI works is that you walk in, there are public spaces for washing our hands, but then there are a series of closed stalls that are floor to ceiling doors with locks on the doors.
And studies have shown that this type of toilet actually reduces the wait time for women from six minutes to under one minute.
Why am I talking about efficiency and toileting and what does that have to do with chief stadium? Because you know what, if we don't care about the privacy and safety of Kansans, then we should at least care about the bottom line of our stakeholders.
When this new chief stadium is being built, the designers have the right or should have the right to choose a structure and an infrastructure that operates in the most efficient way possible.
Because you know what, if someone is standing in line for the restroom, you know what they're not doing, they're not buying the $30 beer or the $40 hot dog or whatever it is that they're going to be selling and people are going to be missing out on money.
So if you can't oppose this bill for safety and privacy, then you should at least be thinking about the bottom line.
More of my colleagues will speak about this. Thank you for your indulgence and I hope you learned something.
Remember, when it comes to restroom history, knowing is half the battle.
Is there any other member wishing to speak to the bill the chair recognizes representative boy.
Thank you, Mr chair. Thank you, Mr chair. Would the carrier stand for questions, please.
Yes, thank you. I've got some logistics questions on.
So upon establishment when this bill is enacted when it becomes law on that day.
There are Kansans whose driver's license and birth certificate will be invalid at the same time.
I had a question. Yeah, is that that's my understanding is that am I understanding that correctly.
Yes, well, and they're in there.
Yes, they have to have the state ready to start correct their birth certificate.
Okay, so they're not going to get notice.
That those are invalid until they are in fact invalid. And then we have individuals without a birth certificate without a driver's license.
And if they need to renew that, how can they operate their motor vehicle.
To go get that new driver's license.
Well, I would suggest that they know if their val if their driver's license is valid or invalid because they've changed it if it's if it's invalid. So they know.
Okay, thank you. I'm assuming there. Well, I would do have one more about that.
Assuming that they know we're doing this right now.
And then what other so immediately left without a certificate and a valid driver's license. What if they haven't gotten a passport yet. What other types of ID can they use to prove citizenship and identification.
Sorry, I'm not understanding the question. So we're going to invalidate birth certificates driver's license.
What do Kansans have and Americans have other than a passport.
And if they don't have that yet, like what do they have with them that they can have valid.
I just need to get their new birth certificate and driver's license. All right. Thank you.
I think the logistics of this are a nightmare for somebody, especially.
We know across this country right now American citizens are being asked to show their papers.
And we're going to take away the papers of about 1700 people upon when this bill takes effect.
Hopefully they're paying attention if they're not.
We're leaving them without a way to prove their citizenship and without a way to drive their motor vehicle to even get the new paperwork.
I think that's incredibly just unfair. And I don't think that the logistics process of this has been outlined well enough because we should have at least provided some.
Send some form of ID or something that could be recognized in case the individual is stopped by law enforcement who would have the discretion of whether or not to further penalize these individuals if they don't have.
In fact, a valid driver's license. So I think this making a dangerous situation for people a confusing situation for law enforcement.
And I just don't think that's been well, well thought out on this.
I also want to, I've heard a few times today talking about how many times we've been talking about this issue.
And the other day I had a social media memory from 2016 that I had posted about a particular bathroom bill.
That's a decade, a decade of a crusade against transgender people that for some reason I guess along the way.
There have been some folks that picked up that did make people maybe think differently or consider their position about transgender people differently.
And that just makes me really, really sad. And I wish that if we would take on an issue that we're going to fight for a decade on that we'd figure out how to feed kids at school, how to feed them breakfast and lunch.
I wish that we would figure out how to fund special education.
There's so many things that I feel like we all would care about together that would just make a lot more sense to garner support around and fight for for over 10 years.
I have received emails today, one from a constituent whose sister is transgender.
So I also don't want to lose sight of the fact that real people are going to be impacted by this summer paying attention.
They might be able to get ahead of all the paperwork disaster that's about to hit them.
Others will not.
It's egregious.
I'm going to vote no on this bill and I encourage you to reject it specifically based on the discrimination and the terrible logistics that we're going to put forward on these real, real people that are going to get these notices.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Is there any other member wish to speak to the bill? Chairman recognizes representative Simmons for the second time.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. I have a question for the carrier of the bill.
Thank you. So I shared with the body my personal experience.
If someone were to come up to me in the women's restroom, suggest I am not a woman. What's the enforcement protocol in the legislation?
The person makes a claim themselves, not to you.
But I mean, it's all laid out in the bill, which I'm guessing you know.
I like I'm smart. Thanks, representative.
Yeah, so I mean, all the claims are really clearly laid out in the bill. I mean, so who would the claim go to?
The claim goes to, I mean, are you talking about are they making?
Well, okay, let me rephrase. I'll rephrase. There's different.
Let's say I walk into the restroom and I say that woman right there looks like a man. Who would I call?
You would make a claim and it's very laid out. What you do, it has to have certain, it has to be written.
It's to the attorney general. I think hang on. Let me just make sure.
We you can look at this too. If you want to, I assume maybe you already have an idea.
Hang on. I thought I'd ask the bills expert.
And a long day.
Hang on. Yep. So.
A person they file a complaint. This is on the top of page three with the attorney general against the government entity.
Oh, that's against the government entity. Is that who you wanted to make the claim against?
There's different things. There can be a personal cause of action.
I would like you to please explain all the enforcement protocols listed in this legislative.
Three different things.
And I'm going to make it really quick. You can make a claim to the attorney general against the government entity.
And before that happens, there's a long list of things that have to happen and investigation and the government entity is given time to cure.
Three days at first and then later, once they've done investigation, 15 days to cure it, they've given time. So that's.
And then there's also a violation for an individual to enter the multi place, the multi occupancy space. Again, there's it's laid out. Look at page four.
They have to talk the complaint has to have the date location statement that repeated violations may result.
So, I mean, if I may, how would I get the name of the individual that I'm filing a complaint about?
And they expected to give me their, no, you are not making a claim to that person. You were making a claim and they, and there is an investigation.
And do we know what the fiscal note would be on those investigations? And does the attorney general's office have the capacity to carry out these investigations?
You need to consider more FTEs. This is such a problem. Yeah, I don't think so, but I'll let you figure that out. So, well, this is your bill representative, not my problem to figure out.
I have one more question for the carrier of the bill.
Okay.
Some religions consider it to be against their religion to only consider two sexes. I would like to know would this be an infringement by the government on their religious freedom, such as Native Americans in the state of Kansas.
But I suppose religious freedom is not something that the representative is going to spend time on today.
The, the, the representable refrain from impugning the motives of the fellow.
There was, there was no impugning taking place respectfully. I asked for details.
Please continue.
Concern of religious freedom.
I have one more question for the carrier of the bill.
Okay.
This bill was this bill any different from racially segregated bathrooms when white women used to claim the black men were so scary and they didn't want to be in the bathroom with them.
Well, I have the answer. She was right. I had the answer to some of them. And that one is they provided an alternate bathroom. We all know how that went down. It was deemed unconstitutional.
This body has rejected to provide even that courtesy under this bill.
And I do believe in the history books, not my personal opinion, not impugning anyone in this chamber.
Those actions were considered to be exceedingly egregiously bigoted. And we know that now in the course of American history. Thank you.
I would like to introduce an amendment.
The amendment appears short. The clerk will read.
I move to an in-house substitute for SB 2, 4, 4 on page 10, following line 15 by inserting new section seven, the board of education of each school district shall adopt curriculum for each of the grades kindergarten through 12 on violence prevention.
This includes instruction on emotion regulation, anger management, and active consent. Such instructions shall be provided to students enrolled in the district who are male and by remembering sections accordingly on page one in the title in line 13 after the semicolon by inserting
requiring instruction in elementary and secondary public schools on violence prevention.
Representative, you may explain your amendment. Thank you. We spent the entire day today talking about women's safety girls. Representative, you need to turn in the amendment before we can proceed with the debate on the amendment.
They have it.
Apparently they do not. Could you please check with the clerk?
Okay, I apologize. Representative, you may continue.
Thank you.
We spent the entire day. In fact, the last roughly five hours talking about women's safety.
I think we should be teaching kids how to talk about safety, how to talk about their safety, how to learn consent.
So that women like myself and other women who have been referenced in this body do not have to go through a sexual assault.
There's no reason that we should not be making sure that our youth know what's right, what's wrong.
There's no downside whatsoever to this.
I would please encourage you to support ensuring that the boys in our schools are learning what consent is and how to treat women.
I encourage your support on this amendment.
Is there any member wishing to speak to the amendment? The chair recognizes representative Humphreys.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. We will challenge the Germanis on this amendment.
The Germanis of the amendment has been challenged. The rules committee will meet and deliberate.
Thank you.
The chair recognizes the chair of the rules committee for a ruling.
Thank you, Chair. The ruling is that it's not germane.
The amendment pertains to curriculum and K through 12 with respect to violence.
And it instructs that there should be some instruction on emotion regulation, anger management and active consent.
It doesn't concern driver's license. It doesn't concern, you know, the appropriate bathroom to be used.
And to the extent that concerns privacy and are actually safety, I guess it expands the bill way beyond what the bill is narrowly focused on.
So it is not germane.
We're back on the bill. Representative, you still have the floor.
Thank you. Please vote no on this bill.
Is there any further discussion? The chair recognizes Representative McDonald for the second time.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
You know, I can't quit thinking about this construction thing.
And while I've been given assurances from the bring of the bill that we aren't going to have to do any construction.
I heard something conflicting from my friend from garden city.
He said there aren't going to be very many instances where we have to redo bathrooms.
So, whether it's not very many or, or none, just to be safe so that we can look out for our municipalities, I have an amendment.
The amendment appears short clerk will read.
I move to amend house substitute for SB 244 on page two following line 22 by inserting.
Three, the subsections shall not apply any public building in existence on the effective date of this act.
Compliance with the provisions of this subsection requiring the governing body or the chief administrative officer.
If no governing body exists to remodel or reconstruct such public building.
Representative, you may explain your amendment.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
You know, we haven't even spoken with our municipalities yet because we haven't given it. We haven't been given the time to do that. And so out of an abundance of caution.
I think in consideration for our municipalities or schools.
Our community colleges, our universities.
We need to probably go ahead and vote in this amendment because this gives us a chance to grandfather it in any current buildings that are.
Already owned by the state or the municipalities any any government owned building.
This would not apply to them.
I understand that you guys feel like this is an urgent thing, but if really there are no.
Construction costs associated or if there aren't very many, then then this should be an easy yes for you all.
It's fine for us to go ahead and from here forward, keep this in mind. We build new bathroom facilities and new government buildings.
But for the government buildings that already exist, my amendment would just grandfather it in so that this would not apply.
We wouldn't have to worry about construction.
And we can move forward with this in mind as we design bathrooms in the future.
I stand for questions.
Is there any member wishing to speak to the amendment? The chair recognizes representative Humphreys.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. I would just ask for you to vote this amendment down. Thank you.
Is there any further discussion? Seeing none represent McDonald, you may close.
I guess I'm a little puzzled if this is going to not cause any construction.
What does it hurt to vote? Yes, on this amendment.
I understand that we have been a little bit trying today and we've been dragging things out, but I bring this amendment with serious concern about the finances for our municipalities or school districts for the repercussions intended or not.
This really helps give some surety. This law is very vague in this area.
So I'd really appreciate a yes vote on my amendment so that we can make sure and reassure all of our constituents, our cities, our schools that we're not going to raise property taxes to fix bathrooms to comply with this bill in the next month.
We can just make sure that every existing government building does not apply and we can move forward with this in mind.
Do you close on your amendment? I was trying to remember. I close on my amendment. Thank you.
You've heard the motion by represent McDonald do amend all those in favor signify by saying aye.
All opposed nay.
The nays appear to have it. The nays do have it. The motion fails. You still have the floor representative.
I really appreciate the enthusiasm I'm hearing in this room at this late hour.
Thank you for your patience. Thank you, especially to the gallery for those of you who have stuck with us.
And thank you for those of you who are watching online. I just want Kansas to understand.
This is serious legislation. We are here for serious purposes and there are going to be a lot of unintended consequences and lawsuits as a result of these poor decisions today.
I'll be voting no on this bill. Thank you for your patience.
Is there further discussion? The chair recognizes representative car.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Small people. I'm blessed. You should be too. With the carry of the bill, please stand for a question.
I am just curious as to the origin of this particular legislation with this.
By any means be associated with what the maga movement has in detailed in project 2025.
I'm not familiar with exactly what you're talking about, which part of the maga movement in 2025 that you're referring to.
So the part of the maga movement in 2025, this sounds exactly like the bill you're introducing. That part.
Well, you know, it's funny. When I was doing research on this and what I was going to do, I went back to 2017.
We had a similar bill in this house that was introduced in the house and the Senate actually.
So, you know, this is the dignity of women being able to be in private spaces goes.
Goes back a long time and I don't think it's was initiated by any one event, but maybe the myriad of instances that I'll talk about later where women have not been safe in private places.
I didn't ask a question about the event or the private places. My question was, was this bill introduced because of what's in project 2025.
Thank you. Not that I know what.
Well, just so you know, if you didn't know.
Almost this exact language is in that project 2025 bill.
You know, I have to say this that says I've been here this.
You know, this has been very interesting.
You know, I don't have many people that I consider friends.
I just don't. I'm not that kind of guy.
And in that I certainly don't have friends that are members of alternative lifestyles.
However, however, I do understand when people are being singled out.
For whatever reason, you know, and.
My mother raised me not just to take care of myself, but to additionally take care of those people who are unable.
To adequately defend themselves.
And I'm afraid this is what we had.
You know, I know what this feels like.
One of my colleagues stood here earlier and gave us some detailed history about an experience that she had earlier in life.
As I look at this this this piece of legislation, I can tell you about it.
I can give you a detailed experience about something that happened to me.
Not so long ago in life.
As this legislation attempts to point out that there are fears in women because of certain people.
I can tell you that.
I have been a victim.
Of some of that not too long ago.
In a place where I was employed.
A complaint was filed against me.
For being nothing more than a scary black man.
Not that I've done anything.
But.
I was simply a scary black man and then I was forced to defend myself.
Because of what I would consider.
Bigoted behavior.
And that's what we have here.
In my opinion.
We have.
Bigoted behavior.
That has.
Generated legislation.
In an attempt.
To take advantage of people.
I'm not impunity in the motives of anybody.
I'm telling a story about what took place here and excuse me young lady if you weren't here.
You should probably read about it.
There will be a storm in the chamber represent please refrain from adjusting your colleagues in the chamber.
I don't believe I addressed anyone in particular.
As I look as I look around the room there's more than one person that might be considered female.
In the room.
I'll continue.
Again.
This legislation.
That can certainly be construed.
As taking advantage of certain groups of people.
That we have spent hours and hours and hours today.
We have absolutely overlooked.
All of those things that may have been more advantageous.
To Kansans.
But this is what we choose to spend our time debating.
And it singles out a group of people.
Who again.
May not be able to stand and fight for themselves I would just like to say thank you to my colleagues for putting up such a fight.
I would urge you to vote against this bill.
Because as what one of my colleagues mentioned earlier.
Yeah.
This sounds an awful lot.
Like.
Laws in the past that.
Kept certain people from bathrooms.
Drinking fountains.
The front doors of businesses.
I won't even continue.
You know where I'm going.
So I urge you not to support this.
I don't have much.
Faith in the fact that you won't.
Thank you anyway.
Is there further discussion the chair recognizes represent mostly.
Or the second time.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
And thank you, everyone for, you know, it's been out over here.
But thank you all for sticking around for this.
I think this is a very important topic.
The conversation has come up of what is this going to cost us.
And I know that we're thinking about it in taxpayer dollars.
I want to hark in with one of my previous colleagues what they said.
Back in the day when they had separate but equal.
One of the things that we failed to talk about when we have those
conversations is we fail to talk about the fact that a lot of folks were
paying taxpayer dollars to keep buildings running and then they were
not able to have access to it.
I'm going to let my friend wake up over here.
He's sleeping.
You're not enough a little bit.
So I would say that yes, that is a problem.
But that's not why I'm here.
I'm here to talk about what it will cost us.
There's a state that's to the east of us known as North Carolina.
They try to pass a very similar bill.
I know that we're very excited for things like the Chiefs coming here
and they're going to play here.
We're very excited about having the World Cup.
We're very excited about potentially be able to bring in new business
and all those things.
But you know what businesses doesn't like.
They don't like they don't like for their people to not feel safe to be here.
We do not have mountains.
We do not have oceans, but we do have good schools.
We have good people in Kansas.
And what we're doing here is we're going to make it where Kansas is going to
become less less enticing for people to come here.
For instance, when North Carolina passed their bill in 2017,
it cost the state $3.76 billion.
$3.76 billion because of the fact that they lost opportunities to host
NCAA championships.
They lost opportunities to host the all-star game.
They lost opportunities to do all those things.
So all the celebration that you're doing for the socialized building of the
Kansas City Chiefs stadium is all going to go to waste.
What happens?
Oh, you know, the Kansas City Chiefs might be, you might carve that out,
even though that is a publicly owned business.
Seems like you guys care about business in that front.
But what are people going to feel like when they want to come to our other
institutions?
They'll feel safe in Kansas.
And I don't think people will feel safe in Kansas.
And I'm going to end with this.
I'm going to once again remind you that you are more likely to be hurt by a
member of the clergy than you are by a trans person.
So I'm going to end with this.
One second.
First, I'm going to talk about Ted Hager.
Ted Hager was a very anti-LGBT person who lost his church because he was
soliciting masseuses.
But those met masseuse was a lease of age.
So there's no threat with that.
Those could be two consenting adults.
So I don't care what two consenting adults do.
But I do care about what happens to children.
And I do care because it seems like everybody cares about that as well.
So I'm going to talk a little bit about
a new trial day set for youth pastor Zachary Radcliffe,
a child sexual abuse charges pile up to 60.
That is someone who performed at CPAC, a conservative organization.
And I'm also going to end with North Carolina Republican official who
secretly dropped his granddaughter and her friends hit with new charges.
None of those people were trans.
Thank you.
Is there further discussion?
The chair recognizes Representative Wooder.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
And thank you, body for once again, another spirited discussion on an issue
that does nothing for lowering the cost of living in Kansas.
It does nothing to make it more affordable to live, work,
or raise a family in here, which is what we've continued to hear everyone
at the start of this session say they were going to be focused on.
Yet again, we're doing another culture war issue.
And that's going to be one of the first things we send to the governor's desk.
You know, I know that debates like this can sometimes get heated.
I know that there are times where people want to stand up and call point of order
and suggest that people are imputing the motives.
We have to start talking to each other more and listening to each other more.
This very bill and some of the proponents of it have even said
that this bathroom provision was brought because of one of our new colleagues.
It was just a few years ago where we had a former representative from Wichita
who was elected as the first openly trans legislator in Kansas
and a number of colleagues, actually only one colleague,
complained so much to the media that there was all this national attention about it.
That representative showed up to work, did her job and paid in peace.
And so when we see bills like this, it's once again one of those things where it's like,
what are we doing here?
I feel like this is not feel like I know.
This is the eighth year in a row that I've had to stand up here and say,
what on earth are we doing shrinking down government small enough to fit into our bathrooms,
our bedrooms, our physician offices, and everything else?
It's been a musical in high school called Year in Town where they were policing
who could go to the bathroom and how much they had to pay to pee.
And I thought it was so far fetched and wild.
And yet here we are debating a very similar reality.
The process with this bill is egregious.
And I know that some say, well, we followed what is allowed through the procedures and processes.
Kansans, whether you agree with them or disagree with them on this issue, deserve to be heard.
Anyone that supports this bill should be able to show up to a hearing and say so.
Anyone that is opposed to this bill should be able to show up and say so.
And through that hearing process and allowing testimony, which just the underlying bill,
the gender marker bill alone was scheduled with less than 24 hours notice.
And people had to turn in their testimony by 10am.
And luckily, thankfully to the chair in her office made an exception where people,
if they couldn't print those copies and turn them in on time, they were still able to have their testimony sent to the committee.
So I appreciate that.
But our office riled up every office assistant and intern we could find to get Kansans testimony printed, copied, and turned in.
If this isn't something that is so deeply unpopular to the public, then why are you doing it in a rushed and hidden process?
Again, you have the numbers. You have a super majority that you expanded after the last election.
You have the ability to pass these things.
You have the ability to schedule a hearing, allow the public to come way in.
And at the end of the day, we can get up here and debate and disagree.
And that's how the democratic process is supposed to work.
And so I hope and I know that the hour is long and people have been going all day and I feel for our revizers who stayed up all night and orally this morning getting these things done.
But shoving bills like this through the process this quickly is wrong.
I also heard a lot today about protecting Kansans.
And my disagree with your approach to doing so.
But through that, there is a very real situation if this bill is passed into law, where there is someone that does present as mail that shows up in a restroom.
There is a reality in which someone who has transitioned in a female shows up in a men's restroom if they're complying with the law.
In Kansas under our hate crime statutes, we penalize crimes at higher levels.
If someone walks into a restroom and a trans man who is buff and bearded and they decide that they're frustrated and they're going to take matters into their own hands.
Yes, it's a crime to assault someone, but doing so simply because of their gender identity or expression or sexual orientation should be included as an elevated level.
And with that, Mr. Chair, I have an amendment.
The amendment appears long. Is there objection to waiving the reading of the amendment?
Is there objection? Okay. There's an objection. Clerk will read.
I move to amend House substitute for SB 244 on page eight following line 29 by insertion is waived.
Would you like to explain the amendment representative? I would. Thank you, Mr. Chair.
This amendment essentially changes parts of the provisions of law.
And on page three of the amendment, you'll see the underlying portion that just in addition to our current hate crimes statutes that include race, color, religion, ethnicity, national origin.
Or sexual orientation of the victim of the offense was motivated. We are adding gender identity. So that way, if someone does create assault someone because of their gender identity, because they're following our law that they are added to our hate crimes.
And with that, I'd be happy to send for questions.
Is there any member wishing to speak to the amendment?
The chair recognizes, I'm sorry, the chair recognizes represent car Michael.
I'll share a few questions for the maker of the amendment.
Hello. Nice to see you, Mr. Leader.
This seems like a good idea. My recollection is that the United States Supreme Court decided a few years ago that.
Gender or at least as it relates to sexual orientation is in fact a protected class under the Americans with Disabilities Act. Do you recall if that's correct?
If you're proposing the question, I would assume maybe.
In all hander, the reason that I was a bit hesitant was I wasn't expecting to talk about this today.
Do you know if the Kansas Human Rights Commission is now accepting complaints that are based on same sex, if you will, discrimination.
Thank you for the question. It's my understanding that the Human Rights Commission has used that ruling on when it comes to non discrimination.
So before that ruling, it was legal under Kansas law to fire, deny housing or refuse business to people based on their sexual orientation or gender identity.
This I think is slightly different because this imposes penalties as a hate crime versus just the non discrimination portion of the Kansas Act against discrimination.
Thank you, Mr. Leader.
I do appreciate the leader refreshing my recollection because I wasn't thinking that we're going to be at this point this late in the afternoon, but he did point out the distinction that was the thrust of my questions, and that is under under this amendment.
It would make these types of offenses hate crimes as opposed to civil violations of either the Americans with disability.
Excuse me, under either the Civil Rights Act or under the Kansas Act against discrimination. And by the way, I referred a few moments ago to the ADA.
That may have applicability and some other context related to the bill, but that was not the thrust of what I was referring to and I apologize if I misled anyone.
Sounds like a very good idea to me long overdue. Thank you.
Is there further discussion on the amendment?
Chair recognizes represent Humphrey Humphreys.
Thank you, Mr. Chair. We will challenge their Germanus on this amendment.
The Germanus has been challenged. The rules may well meet in the Brenda judgment.
Thank you.
Would the rules chair make a ruling on the Germanus of the amendment?
I need Mike. There we go. Thank you. Thank you, Mr. Chair.
The amendment is not germane. The amendment concerns essentially some sort of attack on different individuals.
Hello, concerns.
Tax on certain individuals based on race, color, religion, ethnicity, that's all in the law now.
And this is adding gender identity to that crime.
The underlying bill contains one to driver's licenses and two to the use of.
Private spaces in public.
Public entity bathrooms and lockers and so forth. And I don't believe it's to remain to that.
We're back on the bill. You have the floor representative. Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Darn.
Well, I do hope that since it seems like this is on the fast track to passage and becoming law.
I do hope that we will consider the unintended consequences that were mentioned earlier.
And that if we're truly looking to protect all cans and not just those.
We're looking to protect all cans and we'll make sure to enact hate crimes legislation in a separate bill later on.
You know, I got involved in this whole political process because I was represented by someone who I believed after talking to folks across my district helping others.
Who were running for school board and city council and state legislature that the for the person that represented me was out of touch with our district.
The person before him was the former chair of judiciary.
And I think that people oftentimes forget that our former my district went from our former representative Lance Kenzer and former representative Randy Powell.
To a very proud.
Out.
Young.
Democrat.
And so as we continue to see change in the state.
I hope that you will continue to listen to the people that you're elected to represent as was so eloquently stated last year by one of our colleagues from Wichita.
We truly do spend some a little bit too much time listening to listening to one another in this building instead of the people that sent us here.
I hope that you will vote no on how substitute for Senate bill 244. Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Is there further discussion the chair recognizes represent boatman.
Thank you, Chair.
And thank you, first of all, foremost to all of the staff for your time and energy in making this long debate as possible as productive as it could be.
Secondly, I have sat here for five and a half hours and listened to this entire room debate my humanity and my ability to participate in the most basic functions of society.
And from the bottom of my heart, I hope none of you have to ever sit through something like that.
I've been elected official for 20 days. This is my 20th day.
In those 20 days.
Among other things I have sat and listened in presentations with.
Very dense presentation set times lots of good at valuable information.
For instance, there was a very good presentation about the state of capers.
And what we are doing to take care of our state employees and retirees.
I went to a informational luncheon and learned a lot of new information about the health of rural Kansans and the struggles that often come with access to health care outside of urban centers.
I sit on four committees. None of them are the queer committee.
I've sat in a hearing about pesticides. I have never thought I would be more interested in pesticides than I was the past couple of days.
I've sat in a hearing about adding fetal alcohol spectrum disorder to disabilities class so that students with FASD are able to access effective education.
I've sat in hearings about whether we should allow chaplains either on a paid or voluntary status into our public schools to provide moral and religious support to our students.
I sat in another hearing where we debated whether or not we were going to offer our Kansas students effective mental health services while they're in school.
That's what I have done on my days outside of this chamber.
In fact, today, this morning, I sat in a two hour hearing about crypto kiosks.
And if anybody likes to go down a rabbit hole, I suggest that one.
But there was some real serious discussions going on about protecting our most vulnerable Kansans, the elderly who are vulnerable to scams, especially when it comes to technology.
Our kids and parental rights and the right for parents to make good informed decisions about how they want their children to be raised.
And then I come to the floor.
And I've had the opportunity to vote on a performative bill to denounce the United Nations.
A worldwide organization originally proposed by Franklin D. Roosevelt.
That's a vote on a resolution for the Constitution of states, as if we're in some Orwellian version of Gone with the Wind.
And then today.
Now, while I am somewhat flattered that this chamber seems so obsessed with me.
I want to take this opportunity to apologize to my constituents for this massive waste of time.
And tax payer money.
This bill, whether it passes or not, has already cost taxpayers thousands of dollars, all of us sitting here all day long.
We've made a lampoon, a procedure and due process.
And flippant arguments such as we've already talked about this before is not a legitimate reason to short circuit democracy.
Now, I think my colleagues have aptly and repeatedly demonstrated through both their words and their votes that this bill is not about children's safety and privacy.
It is not about women's safety.
It's not about protecting victims of violence.
It's certainly not about doing the business of the people.
Even the arguments in favor of accurate documents to assist law enforcement are dubious at best.
What this bill is about is about sending a very clear message to people who are transgender that you are not welcome and you are not safe here.
It's about making participation in society as perilous and as punitive as humanly possible for transgender canons or just people who visit Kansas.
I did not come here to debate my right to life.
I came here because I live in a working class district and working class districts deserve working class representation.
A little bit about my district.
I'm from House District 86.
That's in the southeast portion of Wichita.
In my district, there are nine educational facilities.
There's a juvenile correctional facility.
There are 1,400 veterans in my district.
25% of the population of my district is Hispanic.
District 86's median income is two thirds that of the average of Kansas and the United States.
20% of my district lives below the poverty line and that includes 27% of children in my district.
The high school graduation rate of my district is 80%.
I am a college graduate who has chosen to stay in Kansas and do what I can to make this a great place to live.
So amidst the ongoing brain drain of Kansas.
Am I a boon to Kansas?
Or am I a danger?
I'm a United States Air Force veteran.
And ever since Brownback rescinded protections for LGBTQ state employees.
I have always wondered as a veteran, am I revered and honored?
Or am I just disparaged and cast aside as a trans person?
I'm an elected official, like almost everybody in this room.
Am I afforded all of the rights and responsibilities of an elected official?
Or do I need to just go waste my time at facilities asking where I'm allowed to take a dump?
Regardless of the answer to those questions, I am here to do real work.
I am here to find ways to keep Kansans in their homes.
I'm here to make health care affordable and accessible for Kansans and their families.
I'm here to hopefully strengthen public education for all of our children, including those in special ed.
I'm here to advocate for a livable wage for Kansans so that they can afford the rising prices and costs of literally everything.
We owe it to our constituents to spend our time and their treasure on laws that strengthen our families and our state as a whole.
And not on culture war nonsense that pits Kansans against each other unnecessarily.
I desperately want to believe that this collection of adults is astute enough to drop this bill, vote no, and focus on helpful legislation.
Instead of harmful legislation, I guess we'll see.
Thank you chair. Is there any further discussion? Seeing none, Representative Humphries, you may close.
Thank you. Quick announcement. We're not having judiciary committee.
Not to cancel that so.
Okay, thank you all for the discussion.
I will make this as quick as I can, but I cannot not talk about a few points because there has been false information and false narratives misinformation that's going on today and I just must address it.
First of all, this is not about a fiscal note. I'm asking you, what do you think the fiscal note might be? I know there's not one. I understand that.
But if you think about what it might be, this does not require any construction. Okay, so that.
This is not about skirting the rules, which I heard today. All the rules and procedures were followed. They might be just tasteful to some, but they were followed.
This is not about what a person looks like or the identity that they claim.
I want to tell you what it is about. It is about joining 19 other states who have passed this sort of legislation. The most recent was Texas.
One of the fastest growing states in our nation.
What this bill does, it restores clarity for administrators and our schools. They want to know what to do about this and this gives them clarity.
It reaffirms that this is how most government buildings are already structured with a male restroom and a female restroom.
That's how our government, by far, the majority of the government buildings are structured that way.
This is about the most recent poll across the country that a majority of Americans agree that men and women should have separate spaces.
And then something I really want to know, and this is probably the thing that's troubled me the most, is that we've heard this isn't harming what we're doing.
It's not harming anybody. Why aren't why are we doing this? And I want to tell you, I don't have a prop.
I have pages of list of sexual assaults that have happened across the country in restrooms.
For the sake of everyone, I'm not going to go into detail, but I have pages with lists on them of news articles and things that have happened across the country and in Kansas.
So there is harm going on because we don't have this bill in place because right now anyone can walk in any bathroom.
This is about making it really clear who can go in each restroom.
This is about making it clear that states have a duty to protect the privacy and the safety of women.
That's what this is about, the privacy and safety of women.
This is about the fact that all Kansasans have value because all are made in the image of God, all the born and the unborn.
This is about the legislative intent because that was part of it. This is what the legislature, that first part of the bill, it's about clarifying our legislative intent.
This is about accuracy. This is about biology.
And the last thing I'll say is this is about truth.
So, Mr. Chair, I move that when the committee rises in reports, the report Senate Bill 244 as amended favorably for passage.
You've heard the motion from Representative Humphries to report, substitute for Senate Bill 244 favorably.
All those in favor signify by saying aye.
All opposed nay.
The ayes appear to have it. The ayes do have it. The motion passes.
This concludes our general orders. The chair recognizes the majority leader for a motion.
Mr. Chair, move your ayes and report.
You've heard the motion of the rise and report. All in favor signify by saying aye.
Ayes no. The motion passes.
The clerk will read the committee report.
Mr. Speaker, your committee, the whole recommends that sub SB244 be passed as amended.
Speaker recognizes representing Proctor to adopt the committee of the whole report.
Thank you, Mr. Speaker. I move the adoption of the committee report.
You've heard the motion to adopt the committee report. All those in favor signify by saying aye.
All opposed no. The ayes have it. The committee report is adopted.
Speaker recognizes representing Croft for a motion.
Mr. Speaker pursuant to House Rule 2306, I move that House Bill 213 to be withdrawn from the calendar under the order of business.
General orders and be referred to the committee on child welfare and foster care.
You've heard the motion. All those in favor signify by saying aye.
All opposed no. Motion passes.
Mr. Speaker, pursuant to House Rule 2306, I move that HCR 5015 be withdrawn from the calendar under the order of business and general orders and be referred to the committee on education.
You've heard the motion. All those in favor signify by saying aye.
Opposed no. The ayes have it. Motion passes.
Mr. Speaker recognizes representing Croft for another motion.
Mr. Speaker pursuant to House Rule 23311, I move that emergency be declared that it's Senate Bill 24 or be advanced to the order of business final action on bills and concurrent resolutions.
You've heard the motion. All those in favor signify by saying aye.
Opposed no.
The ayes appear to have it. The ayes do have it. The motion passes.
The vision has been called the clerk will open the roll.
Of all members had an opportunity to cast their vote.
The clerk will close the roll. Does any does any member desire to change his or vote.
It's just a division. Representative Carr votes no.
Eighty seven in favor thirty five thirty thirty six against.
The motion passes.
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any other bills and concurrent resolutions. The clerk will read.
H sub First SB two four four and act concerning identification of biological sex.
This is also by committee on judiciary.
imposing criminal and civil penalties for violations,
providing a cause of action for individuals to grieve,
find invasion of privacy or other harm
when accessing a multiple occupancy private space,
amending the women's bill of rights,
defining the term gender to mean biological sex at birth
for purposes of statutory construction,
directing the director of the divisions of vehicles
to invalidate and reissue driver's license
when necessary to correct the gender identification
on such licenses, directing the office of vital statistics
to invalidate and reissue birth certificates
when necessary to correct the sex identification
on such certificates, removing the definition of gender
from the help not harm act.
There's constitutes final action on Senate Bill 244.
The clerk will open the roll and you may record your vote.
As I remember, had an opportunity to record their vote.
The clerk will close the roll.
Does any member desire to explain his or her vote?
Does any member be recognized as Representative Stockville?
Thank you, Mr. Speaker.
This is an embarrassing bill that encourages discrimination.
A bill that has had no constituent review,
has a blank fiscal note and will seriously tarnish
our image as a welcoming state that values all
of our citizens.
This bill will hinder our economic development,
our ability to attract companies, sporting events,
concerts and out of state students
to attend our colleges and universities.
It addresses absolutely none of the issues
our constituents sent us here to address.
I vote no on this bill today,
but the people of Kansas will have the final vote
on this bill and the process that brought this bill
to the floor of the Kansas House of Representatives
on Tuesday, November 3rd, 2026.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Mr. Speaker.
Further explanation of votes?
Representative Hoyt.
Thank you, Mr. Speaker.
I vote no on Hsub for SB 244.
This bill will leave at least 1,700 Kansans
without two reliable methods to prove citizenship
and identification the day it becomes law.
No one deserves this level of harassment
from their government.
This bill is unconstitutional
and it violates basic human decency.
Trans rights are human rights.
I vote no.
Further explanation of votes?
Representative Mosley.
I vote no on this bill, mostly because I don't want to spend
the next 20 years trying to stop this history
from being taught to my niece.
Thank you.
Further explanation of votes?
Representative on.
Thank you, Mr. Speaker.
I vote no in strong protest to the corrupt process
this bill went through.
I vote no for basic human decency.
I vote no for all trans, intersex, and gender diverse Kansans.
And I vote no for my sibling, Keaton.
Keaton, who wants you to know?
It is basic.
We are people and deserve to be treated
with the same dignity and respect as it is.
I vote no for all trans, intersex, and gender diverse Kansans.
We deserve to have documents that match who we are
and to use the bathroom we need to use.
We shouldn't have to be scared all the time
about what's going to happen to us when we wake up tomorrow
and worry that someone is going to make a decision
that will hurt us.
This is what this legislature is doing.
This bill is discriminatory.
It's cruel.
It hurts Kansans.
And I vote no.
Further explanation of votes?
Representative Waitinsaw.
Add it back, Chris.
Thank you, speaker.
Hawkins, Daniel.
Mr. Speaker, I vote no on Senate bill 244.
I understand how important it is to a lot of folks
that we are protecting women and children.
Had the amendment gone on, we truly would be as long as we are
forcing children to be in very nude public situations.
We're not protecting them.
I hope that we can have this as separate legislation moving
forward so that kids can be safe in Kansas.
Thank you.
I recognize this representative Woodard.
Mr. Speaker, I vote no because this bigoted legislation was pushed
through in less than 48 hours, exploding rules meant for real
emergencies in order to silence our voters through bypassing
normal democratic process.
I vote no because this policy is disingenuous and dangerous
to many Kansans, especially members of the transgender
intersex and gender diverse community.
While this bill purports to protect women, in fact seriously
endages the lives of all Kansans through prejudice, segregation
and by prohibiting individuals from accessing restrooms, domestic
violence shelters, rape crisis centers and other essential
spaces and services.
Representative, you two, sorry, Heatherton, neighbor,
Ruiz, Meyer, Carr, Alkala, Martinez, Alsley, Brownlee
Paige, Carmichael, Carlin, Osman, Sawyer,
Barbara Ballard, Amyks and a few others.
Any further explanation of votes?
Does any member desire to change?
Representative Esau on an explanation of vote?
Thank you, Mr. Speaker, and thank you for your tolerance on the
long walk from the back.
Mr. Speaker, on behalf of all the women who have faced the trauma
in the past, I am humbled and honored to vote yes.
Any further explanation of votes?
Does any member desire to change?
Is there a vote?
House?
Seeing ten hands, a call of houses in order, the door
will close the doors.
Members will be in their seats.
And the clerk will call the roll.
No, Mike.
You're Mike.
Helgerson.
Mountain or PASA.
When?
Representative or PASA.
Representative Melton.
What is your vote?
Just up or down?
You cannot vote present.
You have to vote yes or no?
You can come and explain your do an explanation of vote.
Thank you, Mr. Speaker.
I want to thank the president because I think it's
irresponsible to vote on a bill that has been run through so quickly
and not properly vetted.
240 pieces of written testimony not available to us or to the
public and no fiscal note.
My vote cannot be made with information needed to be informed,
fair and responsible for that reason I vote present.
Okay, because we've got a vote going, we cannot, we cannot
vote on our board, so we have to have two-thirds of the
members present who vote no to disallow you to vote present.
If they, if two-thirds vote no, then you must vote yes or no.
So everybody that is voting no, please stand.
No vote will require you to vote.
Okay.
There are 69 no votes.
You have to have two-thirds to approve you to approve your request.
So your request is denied.
You must vote yes or no?
No.
Melton representing, Melton votes no.
Representative or a paisa.
Thank you, Mr. Speaker.
I vote present because of the rest process as well.
In addition to that, I want to ensure that nobody throws a
cloth and I want everybody to stand up and stretch those
legs because as a healthcare provider, I worry about us sitting
here for hours and hours.
In addition to that, I would also like to make sure that I
represent my constituents back home and that they have everything
we need and that they're able to reach out to me in an appropriate time
and manner.
So that's why I vote present.
Again, again, you have to have two-thirds.
Two-thirds, yes, folks, to, to, to receive the ability to vote present.
So we'll do the no vote again.
Those voting no, please stand.
Thank you.
75 voting no, you did not receive the two-thirds.
So your vote is no or a paisa votes no.
Any further changes of vote?
Not seeing 10 hands call is raised.
And voting in favor and 36 against the passage of Senate bill 244,
the same having received a constitutional majority.
The bill is hereby declared past the clerk will record the vote.
Reports of standing committees, the clerk will read.
Committee on Health and Human Services recommends House Bill 2218 be amended
and the bill be passed as amended.
The Committee on Agriculture and Natural Resources recommends HP 2476 be amended
The Committee on Health and Human Services recommends HP 2436 be passed.
Is there any objection to returning to that order of business introduction of bills
and concurrent resolutions?
Seeing no objection, the clerk will read.
House Bill 2575 by Representative Riley and at concerning motor vehicles,
HP 2576 by Committee on Education requested by Tess Ramirez on behalf of
protecting Kansas children from sexual predators and at concerning education,
HP 2577 by Committee on Agriculture and Natural Resources requested
by Representative Fairchild on behalf of Representative Barrett
and at concerning the Department of Administration,
HP 2578 by Committee on Transportation requested by Claudia Hisong on behalf
of the Kansas Farm Bureau and at concerning motor vehicles, HP 2579 by Committee on Transportation,
requested by Representative Hoffman and at concerning roads and highways, HP 2580
by Committee on Commerce Labor and Economic Development requested by Representative K Williams
and at concerning economic development, HP 2581 by Committee on Agriculture and Natural Resources,
requested by Jasmine Kyle on behalf of the Southeast Kansas Humane Society.
And at concerning animals, HP 2582 by Committee on Agricultural and Natural Resources requested
by Taylor Nickel on behalf of Kansas Livestock Association and the Rural Veterinary Workforce
Task Force and at concerning animal care, HP 2583 by Committee on Transportation requested
by Representative Van Houden on behalf of Representative Brantley and at concerning
driver's licenses.
House Bill number 2584 by Committee on Transportation requested by Representative Turner
and at concerning driver's license, HP 2585 by Representative Bill Carpenter
and at concerning motor vehicles, HP 2586 by Committee on Energy, Utilities and
Telecommunications requested by Meghan Boatenberg on behalf of Cox Communications Inc
and at concerning municipalities, HP 2587 by Committee on Health and Human Services,
requested by John Monroe on behalf of Catalyst and at concerning health and health care,
HP 2588 by Committee on Commerce, Labor and Economic Development requested by Representative
Wilcott and at concerning Occupational Licensing, HP 2589 by Committee on Child Welfare and
Foster Care requested by Representative Johnson and Beeler and at concerning children and minors.
Introduction of Original Motions and House Resolution is a quick word.
House Resolution number 6023 by Committee on Legislative Modernization requested by Representative
McDonald, a resolution opposing the federal preemption of state laws that regulate
artificial intelligence.
We have the following temporary replacement or appointments.
Representative Kyle McNorton to replace Representative Sean Wilcott on the House Committee on Social
Services Budget on Friday, January 30th.
This appointment will expire at the end of the day on the 30th.
Representative Dan Goddard to replace Representative Shannon Francis on the House Committee on
Appropriations on Thursday, January 29th.
The appointment expires at the end of the day on the 29th.
Representative Long-Pishney to replace Representative Rick Wilborn on the House Committee on
Elections on Thursday, January 29th.
This appointment expires at the end of the day on the 29th.
Representative Rishi replaces Representative Helgerson on the House Committee on
Appropriations on Thursday, January 29th.
This appointment expires at the end of the day on Thursday, the 29th.
Representative Jared Asley will be ranking minority member on the House Committee on K-12
Education Budget until further notice.
Representative Mary Lynn Poskin to replace Representative Dan Osman on the House Committee,
House Select Committee on Government Oversight.
This is a permanent appointment.
That is all of those changes.
Are there announcements?
Be recognized representing Riley.
Just like to remind everybody about tomorrow morning, 7 a.m.
We're having our prayer breakfast in room 142.
So tomorrow our message comes from Reverend Jason Roberts.
He's a pastor at the River City Church in Lawrence.
Just for your information, just sideline.
He might be a possible Seahawks fan.
So if you want to come and listen to his message, 7 o'clock a.m.
My morning.
Thank you.
Speaker recognizes Reverend Barrett.
Thank you, Mr. Speaker.
Just a reminder that the eradicating human trafficking legislative reception is tonight,
starting now until 7 30 at the beacon.
Also, another representative reminded me to tell everyone that Rokakis is canceled today.
Thank you.
Speaker recognizes Representative Stoddenville.
Thank you, Mr. Speaker.
We will have a gender meeting tomorrow morning 8 31 52 South 8 30.
Speaker recognizes representing Croft for the posting of this sequence for the following day.
Okay, Mr. Speaker, in accordance with house rule 1502, posting of sequence for the succeeding day.
The following bills appear on the calendar of the heading of general orders for January 29th.
House bill 2446 and house bill 2476.
You can recognize the majority leader, Croft for a motion to adjourn.
Okay, Republicans, we will calendar tomorrow morning in the old Supreme Court at 8 a.m.
Mr. Speaker, I move the house adjourn until Thursday, January 29th at 11 a.m.
You've heard the motion, all those in favor signify by saying aye.
All opposed, no.
The ayes have it.
We are adjourned.
Thank you.